c'est la saison des dinosaures
en ce moment les plus grands
paléontologues de la planète fouillent
le territoire canadien pour découvrir un
monde disparu depuis des millions
d'années
le temps en cherchant les traces des
dinosaures
et les plus extraordinaires créatures
jamais vu sur terre revivrons bientôt
car nous marchons sur la piste des
dinosaures
[Applaudissements]
dans cet épisode de sur la piste des
dinosaures deux équipes distinctes
fouillent le sol de l'Alberta à la
recherche de deux espèces de dinosaures
à cornes dans le lit d'une rivière de
grande prairies l'équipe n'est pas cher
dinosaures tentera de résoudre mystère
qui dure depuis 73 millions d'années
qu'est-ce qui a pu causer la mort
simultanée d'un aussi grand nombre de
dinosaures de la même espèce avant que
leurs ossements ne soient emportés par
le courant c'est le pire jour de ma vie
entre-temps dans les bas de l'Inde
albertin l'équipe du vinosaure accorde
cherche le crâne de nouvelles espèces
inconnue on a la collerette il nous faut
maintenant son visage qui s'était éteint
il y a 80 millions d'années
[Musique]
nous sommes à 1000 clever en Alberta
cette vallée fluviale desséchée est un
endroit idéal pour chasser le dinosaure
et au cours des prochaines semaines elle
deviendra la base d'une nouvelle
génération de paléontologue ils y
cherchent un mystérieux dinosaure à
corne l'équipe du dinosaure accorde est
dirigé par David Evans quand je traverse
les Badlands en voyant les fossiles qui
jonchent le sol j'ai l'impression de
parcourir un paysage ancien
la découverte d'un seul fossile plus
radicalement changé la façon dont nous
percevons l'évolution de la planète
à l'âge de 26 ans est devenu le chef du
département de paléontologie du Musée
royal de l'Ontario le plus jeune en
s'entend voilà quand on a affaire ce
poste et j'ai l'impression de réaliser
tous mes rêves au début j'étais comme un
enfant dans un magasin de bonbons
parfois j'aime pas en me disant pourquoi
donc ils ont embauché un gars de 26 ans
leur décision m'a rendu très heureux
le Musée royal de l'Ontario fait
d'importantes découvertes depuis déjà un
siècle et il possède certains des plus
grosses squelettes du pays j'ai eu des
prédécesseurs réputés ce ne sera pas
facile de les remplacer
aujourd'hui David doit faire ses preuves
mais il a déjà fait une découverte qui
risque de changer l'histoire des
dinosaures voilà les ossements d'une
nouvelle espèce de dinosaure à cornes
qu'on n'a jamais vu encore
c'est ce qu'on a sorti du sol pendant la
première année de fouilles
on a pu voir qu'il y avait une
configuration de corne et de crochets
attachés au bouclier crânien qui était
absolument unique
nous avons tous hâte de retourner sur le
terrain pour trouver d'autres fragments
de squelette
c'est ma passion je ne change pas à
laisser un héritage ou à me faire un an
les dinosaures c'est la seule chose qui
m'apporte
rien ne garantit qu'il trouvera des
jours crâniens enfouis dans l'argile
mais devait lavins est prêt à risquer
une nouvelle saison de fouilles pour
s'en assurer
cette fois on espère trouver le reste du
crâne ici surtout les cornes frontales
placées au-dessus des yeux et la corne
nasale les formes particulières de ces
eaux nous aideront à placer cette
nouvelle espèce dans l'arbre
généalogique des dinosaures à cornes
avec plus de précisions
ne porte pas le nom de Badlands sans
raison
cette carrière se transforme rapidement
en four quand la température grimpe à
plus de 40 degrés
[Musique]
l'équipe du dinosaure à corne composée
en grande partie d'étudiants de 3e cycle
creusera un terrain aride sous un soleil
de plomb ceux qui sont au fond de la
carrière ressentent vraiment la chaleur
chaque membre de l'équipe doit prévoir
une réserve quotidienne de quatre litres
d'eau sur le site les coups de chaleur
représente le plus grand danger DVD est
accompagné de son collègue Michael Ryan
un paléontologue canadien qui travaille
pour le musée d'histoire naturelle de
Cleveland on a une dure journée de
travail devant nous le soleil tape mais
ne coéquipier son jeune et vigoureux on
trouvera des tas de fossiles
je veux trouver une série d'ossements
très particuliers
ceux qui prouveront l'existence d'une
espèce encore inconnue
c'est comme un pari le gagnant sera
celui qui aura découvert le premier
vestige
le premier coup de pelle livre des
résultats
on a déterré des dents de tyrannosaures
pour le début d'une première journée de
fouille c'est assez prometteur mais DVD
ne s'intéresse pas au tyrannosaure il
est ici pour prouver l'existence d'une
nouvelle espèce de dinosaure
dinosaure a vécu ici il y a 80 millions
d'années à l'époque les baleines étaient
irriguées par un fleuve et remplit des
plantes nécessaires à la survie de
troupeau d'herbivores de 2 tonnes
45 millions d'années plus tôt les
premiers séraptosiens appelés
protocératops vivaient en Asie ils ont
ensuite migré en Amérique du Nord grâce
à un pont terrestre ils avaient la
taille d'un gros chien un bouclier
crânien mais aucune corne
en fonction des vestiges déjà trouvés on
sait qu'il s'agit d'une découverte
spectaculaire qui nous fournira beaucoup
d'informations sur les débuts de
l'évolution de la famille des dinosaures
à cornes dans le célèbre tricératops
faisait partie
la communauté paléontologique est très
excitée car chacun des ossements
déterrés ici nous en apprendra davantage
sur un animal dont on ignorait même
l'existence il y a deux ans
amis km au nord une autre équipe de
chasseurs de dinosaures se dirige vers
grandes prairie en Alberta c'est une
ville en pleine expansion réputée pour
son pétrole et son grain non loin de là
à Creek on peut voir le site d'un
mystère qui perdure depuis 73 millions
d'années
pendant des millénaires cette rivière a
creusé le lieu remarquable un
gigantesque
de milliers de dinosaures
ce dépôt est l'un des plus riches dépôts
d'ossements de toute la planète
faire des découvertes dans son domaine
est probablement la chose la plus
excitante au monde on ne s'en lasse
jamais
considéré comme l'un des plus grands
paléontologues du monde le chercheur
Philippe Jake a fait des découvertes sur
tous les continents Philippe curry a
inspiré le célèbre personnage du
chasseur de dinosaure du parc jurassique
en 30 ans il a découvert 30 nouvelles
espèces de dinosaures et il a prouvé que
le tyrannosaure chassait en meute on
fait des fouilles à grande prairies
depuis plus de 12 ans on y a excavé des
centaines et des centaines de spécimens
en fait on peut même parler de milliers
de spécimens
et tous ces ossements proviennent d'une
seule espèce de dinosaure le dépôt
d'ossement de pachirinosaure est un site
fantastique parce qu'il nous en a
énormément appris sur la biologie d'un
dinosaure bien défini le pachirinosaure
le pachir rhinosaure appartenait à
l'espèce des sératopiens tout comme son
parent le célèbre tricératops
ces énormes herbivores vivaient dans le
Nord canadien il y a 73 millions
d'années il pouvait mesurer jusqu'à 6
mètres de longueur et pesait environ 3
tonnes
chaque mètre cube de terrain contient
jusqu'à 300 eaux de dinosaures
on estime qu'il reste plusieurs milliers
de pachirinosaures non excavées dans ce
dépôt de semences
l'équipe des pachirinaux de Philippe
curry et elle aussi composée en grande
partie d'étudiants scolaire c'est très
étrange de découvrir autant de
pachirinosaures au même endroit et
absolument rien d'autre
mettons-nous dans la peau d'une équipe
d'enquêteurs aux homicides le mystère
ici ce n'est pas seulement celui qui
entoure la mort d'un grand nombre
d'animaux il y en a un autre quel
phénomène a pu causer la mort simultanée
d'un aussi grand nombre de dinosaures de
la même espèce
[Musique]
l'adjoint de Philippe curry est en
australien de 31 ans
avec lui au Canada c'est la réalisation
de mes rêves d'enfants
en ce moment furban restaurant crâne de
pas cher dinosaures sorti tout droit de
pipe Stone Creek
à l'avant on a le bec qui est un
attribut typique des dinosaures
cératopiens
son globe oculaire devait être là il
avait à peu près la taille de mon point
en arrière on voit les restes du gros
bouclier en collerette qui protégeait
l’arrière du crâne avec une série de
cornes qu'il devait utiliser pour
impressionner d'autres membres du
troupeau et peut-être aussi pour
effrayer les prédateurs
cet animal en compagnie de milliers
d'autres comme lui est mort rapidement
et de façon inattendue
on observe les lieux d'un crime qui
s'est déroulée il y a 73 millions
d'années les pistes sont loin d'être
fraîches
deux équipes deux mystères dans les bas
de l'équipe du dinosaure à cornes
cherchent à excaver une nouvelle espèce
de seratopsien
tandis qu'appa Houston quick l'équipe
des pachirino s'est lancé à la chasse
des fossiles qui pourraient expliquer la
disparition soudaine de milliers de
dinosaures
[Musique]
dans les Badlands de l'Alberta l'équipe
du dinosaure à corne cherche à
identifier une nouvelle espèce de
seratopsien on a la collerette il nous
faut maintenant son visage entre temps à
pipston Creek en Alberta l'équipe
détacherino de Philippe curry cherche à
éclaircir un drame survenu il y a 73
millions d'années on est en présence de
gigantesque suaire donc d'une mort
collective qui a dû avoir lieu en très
peu de temps mais qu'est-ce qui s'est
vraiment passé
quel phénomène a pu exterminer un
troupeau entier de pachirinosaure et
transformer ses forêts en un gigantesque
champ de massacre l'équipe de Philippe
curry n'a que quelques semaines pour
éclaircir la question heureusement après
avoir ôté les débris accumulés depuis 73
millions d'années l'étudiant de 3e cycle
scopersens découvre une énorme pile
d'ossements en premier j'ai déterré un
os de membres puis j'ai excavé le
terrain autour de cet os de là je suis
arrivé à une côte ce qui m'a conduit au
vertèbres puis à une deuxième côte
cette fouille me rappelle un jeu de
bâtonnets on a du mal à ramasser un os
sans tomber aussitôt sur un autre OS
ici j'ai deux eaux crâniens qu'on
appelle les squamosaures les
os spamosophes la base de la collerette
située à l'arrière du crâne vous voyez
c'est joli feston en bordure il nous
aide à établir l'âge de l'animal grâce
au feston on sait qu'il s'agissait au
minimum d'un jeune adulte
cette information aide à faire des curry
à déterminer la cause du décès du
troupeau c'est ce qu'on appelle une
thanatosenose catastrophique parce
qu'elle inclut des animaux de taille
moyenne c'est-à-dire les jeunes adultes
inévitablement ce sont les membres les
plus vigoureux de notre peau
quel événement catastrophique a pu
décimer tout un troupeau y compris ses
membres les plus résistants
la présence d'autant de dinosaures dans
un amant droit éclaire l'équipe sur leur
comportement ce propos devait rassembler
des centaines ou des milliers d'animaux
et ne pouvaient pas rester longtemps au
même endroit
il devait se déplacer constamment
il y a 73 millions d'années ces
dinosaures passaient leurs étés dans
l'Arctique
mais à l'approche des longues nuits
d'hiver il migrai vers le sud jusqu'au
fort et fertile du nord de l'Alberta
un animal muni de jambes robustes mais
courtes n'étaient sans doute pas très
rapide mais l'ampleur de son troupeau
lui donnait une certaine protection
malgré la puissance de leur nombre des
pachirinosaures demeurent vulnérable aux
griffes de l'ultime prédateur vous êtes
un pachirino vous êtes en train de
brouter paisiblement mais vous n'oubliez
pas qu'une meute de tyrannosaure est
peut-être tout près
les vestiges les plus courants dans ce
dépôt d'ossement après les eaux de Pachy
sont les dents de tyrannosaure
ils ont déchiré les carcasses de ces pas
chers innosaures
ça c'est une dent de tyrannosaure
ils ont probablement perdu ses dents
quand ils se sont jetés sur cet amas de
carcasse pour les dévorer
les tyrannosaures ont laissé leur carte
de visite ils ont sûrement déchiré les
carcasses avec enthousiasme mais il me
semble fort peu probable qu'ils aient pu
tuer autant de pas cher rhinosaures
les circonstances de la mort des
pachirinosaures demeure entouré de
mystère
un jour tous les ossements récupérés par
l'équipe de fouilles seront exposés dans
un nouveau musée qui portera le nom de
son célèbre mentor Philippe Jake j'ai eu
du succès en partie parce que j'aime mon
travail et je suis très reconnaissant de
savoir que les gens l'apprécient je
reçois cette honneur avec humilité
tandis que l'équipe n'est pas cherie non
s'efforce de résoudre le mystère du
dépôt d'ossement de pipeston
quickbell descend la rivière à la
recherche de nouveaux sites et de
nouveaux fossiles pour remplir le musée
de son patron
je suis sur la rivière smoky et je
descends le courant c'est presque un
territoire inconnu aucun paléontologue
ne s'y est aventuré depuis une bonne
vingtaine d'années
des fossiles marins découvert le long
des berges prouve qu'il y a 80 millions
d'années et toute cette région était
submergée
philobel est à la recherche du fossile
de reptiles meurtriers de la période du
Crétacé le mosasaure ces reptiles marins
étaient des prédateurs de 15 mètres de
long ils avaient de longs coups des
grosses dents acérées essentiellement
c'était les T-Rex de la mer
comme nos requins modernes ces créatures
étaient de parfaites machines à tuer
préhistorique à l'intérieur de la
mâchoire on voit ce qu'on appelle les
dents externes mais une autre rangée de
dents garnit son palais
elle garantissait que tout ce que
l'animal avait Gobert resterait dans sa
bouche
le squelette du labo de belle n'est
qu'une réplique mais il veut un
squelette authentique pour le musée de
Philippe curry
personne n'a encore réussi à découvrir
un squelette complet idéalement on
aimerait trouver un crâne et un
squelette intact pour avoir une
meilleure compréhension de l'animal
[Musique]
je suis son instinct et grimpant de la
colline
[Musique]
je la laisse pour la nettoyer
les paléontologues bouffent pas mal de
terre sur le terrain
cette zone est assez dangereuse il y a
des saillies de rochers et le terrain
s'effrite continuellement
faire la trouver quelque chose
c'est un gros mollusque un bivalve il
aurait produit une huître de bonne
taille devant moi il y a des espèces de
tubes creusées par des invertébrés qui
s'enfuyaient en vitesse sur le fond
marin
quand on trouve une proie le prédateur
n'est pas loin derrière
c'est super même les petits vestiges
nous donnent de bonnes informations ils
nous disent qu'on est au bon endroit à
la bonne époque et que là où on a trouvé
un fossile il y en aura d'autres
n'a pas trouvé son squelette de mozazor
mais il a fait des trouvailles
intéressantes et il reviendra
[Musique]
dans la chaleur étouffante du site de
Milk River en Alberta l'équipe du
dinosaure à corne cherchent encore à
reconstituer le visage de l'espèce
mystère ce serait une découverte majeure
pour DVD c'est son collègue Michael rain
à ma connaissance aucune autre équipe de
fouilles a réussi à découvrir le
squelette complet d'une nouvelle espèce
de dinosaure accorde ou pas depuis au
moins 50 ans
le chef de l'équipe des devines espère
réussir cette exploit à milk River
David's n'est pas le premier
paléontologue qui a exploré ces collines
pour y trouver des cératopiens il y a
près d'un siècle une des premières
vedettes de la paléontologie a connu la
gloire à l'époque de la grande ruée vers
les dinosaures du début du 20e siècle
il s'appelait Charlie et en 1937 il a
découvert 6 espèces de dinosaures à
corne dans ce lieu
75 ans plus tard DVD veut ajouter une
nouvelle espèce à la collection du Musée
royal de l'Ontario et graver son nom
dans l'histoire de la paléontologie il
n'y a aucune autre découverte aussi
excitante en Alberta depuis un bon bout
de temps
après avoir creusé trois jours sous un
soleil brûlant l'équipe exhume enfin un
premier ossement
on pense qu'il s'agit peut-être d'une
section de membres inférieurs c'est
fascinant parce que jusqu'ici on a
trouvé très peu de fragments de
squelette
finalement on a pris la bonne décision
en excavant la moitié d'une colline et
ça me soulage énormément
ils n'ont pas trouvé le crâne ou la
collerette ton désirée mais ces
ossements les aideront à calculer la
taille du nouveau dinosaure il mesurait
au moins 2 mètres de haut il était donc
beaucoup plus imposant que son ancêtre
asiatique qui avait la taille d'un chien
ils savent que leur dinosaure a vécu il
y a 80 millions d'années à la fin du
Crétacé et qu'il broutait ses Badlands
quand elle formait un vaste espace vert
autour d'une mer intérieure
et ça aussi que leurs dinosaure est un
seratopien un dinosaure à corne doté
d'une collerette comme son cousin le
tricératops
ils ignorent à quoi ressemblent son
visage mais il soupçonne et ils espèrent
qu'il est totalement différent de ceux
des dinosaures déjà identifié
ce qui nous garde éveillé la nuit c'est
la certitude qu'il y a quelque chose
sous le sol à 10 ou 15 cm de nous cette
fois on validera deux ans de travail où
on repartira les mains vides les jours
passent et les deux équipes continuent
leur fouille
l'équipe du dinosaure à corne cherchent
encore le visage d'une nouvelle espèce
affronter les éléments tout en cherchant
l'explication d'une mystérieuse mort
collective préhistorique le climat peut
être très difficile en Alberta
à Paris l'équipe n'est pas cher
dinosaures en taille les parois d'une
carrière à la recherche d'indices pour
identifier les responsables de meurtres
collectif parfois on a de la chance on
trouve les preuves dont on a besoin
Americ River en Alberta le soleil accabe
l'équipe du dinosaure à corne tandis que
paléontologue chevronné débutant fouille
côte à côte dans l'espoir d'exhumer une
toute nouvelle espèce de dinosaure
ce sont mes premières fouilles sur le
terrain
j'étais inscrite à un des cours de Davis
et j'ai eu la chance d'être invité à me
joindre au groupe
tous ceux qui ont une telle ou un ciseau
ont les mêmes chances de trouver un
trésor
dans le domaine on dit souvent qu'on
devient un vrai paléontologue dès qu'on
a brisé un truc important
bien joué c'est super l'os n'est pas
abîmé du tout je crois que ça pourrait
être une côte
d'accord vas-y
ces eaux sont fragiles ils ont peut-être
résisté à l'usure de 80 millions
d'années il faut y aller doucement
mais il pourrait voler en éclat sous un
simple coup de lame
parfait excellent
ta technique était parfaite bravo merci
on a l'impression d'avoir trouvé une
côte presque complète je suis vraiment
fière de mon travail
une partie de plus en plus importante du
dinosaure à cornes inconnu émerge du sol
mais sa tête est encore enfouie sous le
sable
l'étudiant Nicolas Campion a peut-être
trouvé un indice en observant les
couleurs
le rocher est gris l'os et brunâtre et
parce que sa forme est plate mais avec
des bosses il pourrait faire partie du
crâne la forme est courbée en
demi-cercle c'est un des éléments qui
forment la cavité orbitaire on ne peut
pas identifier l'espèce mais c'était
sûrement un dinosaure à cornes
ils savent que le crâne est celui d'un
cératopia mais appartient-il aux
dinosaure à cornes qu'il cherche avec
impatience la forme de sa collerette
leur permettra peut-être de faire une
identification positive la collerette
est une extension du crâne supérieur qui
s'éloigne du corps de l'animal quelques
membres de la famille des sératopsiens
les plus gros crâne jamais répertorié
parmi tous les animaux terrestres de
notre planète les ossements de notre
dinosaure ont été désarticulés mélangés
séparer puis déposez sur le sol à la
manière des artistes judiciaires les
paléontologues doivent rassembler un
maximum de fragments crânien afin de
pouvoir regrets le visage du dinosaure
inconnu le défi c'est de remettre tous
ces fragments en ordre et de
reconstruire le crâne de notre nouveau
dinosaure
tandis que ferruque tente de résoudre
l'affaire non résolue de grandes
prairies ferbel retourne à un site qui
l'a excavé il y a un an
on a travaillé ici au mois d'août
dernier aujourd'hui on vient récupérer
les vestiges encore enfouis dans la
falaise
le site se trouve à l'extrémité d'un
sentier de randonnée pédestre mais les
amoureux de la nature ne sont pas les
seuls à l'emprunter c'est une cartouche
à fusil éjectée
des gens campent ici ils boivent et ils
tirent un peu partout
on ne respecte guère les lois dans le
coin
ils n'ont aucun respect tout ça pourrait
disparaître c'est sans protection
voilà le site qu'on a trouvé l'an
dernier
on avait eu la chance que ce gros rocher
se détache de la falaise on exposant le
squelette partiel d'un hadrosor un
dinosaure avec de canard
les hadrosor étaient de gros herbivores
à bec de canards qui se déplaçaient en
immense troupeau certains adultes
pouvaient mesurer jusqu'à 9 mètres de
long et peser plus de 5 tonnes et demi
mais lorsque philbel veut rouvrir son
site il découvre que des inconnus l'ont
devancé en grimpant la pente j'ai bien
vu que la veste de jute et de plâtre
qu'on avait fabriqué pour protéger les
fossiles avec été arraché et jetés en
arrière
ils ont pris tous les ossements exposés
tout ce qu'il pouvait voir et toucher
ils les ont brisé et jetés en bas
c'est le pire jour de ma vie
je suis au bord des larmes investir tant
d'effort temps de travail dans un site
et constater un pareil mépris pour le
monde naturel je comprends pas
et son équipe vont maintenant tenter de
récupérer quelques vestiges d'adrésor il
faut qu'on recreuse le terrain pour
trouver les ossements qui y sont encore
on vient de trouver le pubis c'est un
fragment du pelvis de l'animal il
disparaît sous ce flanc de falaise alors
il va falloir utiliser le ciseau pour le
sortir tout en douceur on ne doit pas
creuser trop profondément ça pourrait
être dangereux
il couvre les eaux de plâtre pour les
protéger pendant leur voyage vers le
laboratoire ça
va
seulement tu veux que je t'aide non j'ai
une bonne prise
on a déjà l'autre fragments au labo on
l'avait emporté avec le reste du
squelette
à présent on pourra tout assembler
c'est une partie de l'animal vandalisé
on en a beaucoup parlé dans la région je
crois que les gens auront hâte de le
voir
[Musique]
entre temps à pipston Creek l'équipe
n'est pas cherino doit mettre fin à la
chasse une tempête menace son site de
fouilles notre plus grand problème c'est
l'instabilité de la météo
il faudrait absolument protéger le site
parce qu'à chaque épisode de pluie on
doit interrompre le travail alors
qu'est-ce qu'on fait patron
on va déposer une bâche sur le terrain
et installer une grande bâche au-dessus
de la carrière afin de pouvoir
travailler même s'il pleut
Philippe curry doit protéger son site
s'il ne veut pas perdre des indices qui
pourraient l'aider à expliquer la mort
d'un vaste troupeau de dinosaures il y a
73 millions d'années une telle quantité
d'eau et debout pourrait remplir la
carrière très rapidement et après il
faudrait qu'on recommence 2-0 ok vous
pouvez tirer Dame Nature
ignore dans quel état il retrouvera son
site le lendemain matin
mais à mer l'équipe du dinosaure à corne
voit le visage d'une espèce mystère
émergée de la croûte terrestre pour la
première fois en 80 millions d'années on
saura bientôt quelle portion du crâne
est ici
dans les Badlands de l'Alberta l'équipe
du dinosaure à corps n'obtient enfin son
premier aperçu d'une espace inconnue on
espère découvrir d'autres portions du
crâne mais on pourrait très bien échouer
mais à grande prairie en Alberta des
pluies torrentielles frappent la région
provoquant des inondations majeures
ancienne a provoqué une coulée de boue
qui a détruit le site et failli enterrer
les paléontologues vivants
de la carrière avec les autres quand la
paroisse s'est mise assez
ffondrer on sait tous sauvé de là encore
mais deux semaines de travail ont
disparu en l'espace de 2 secondes
la première vue 10 tonnes de rock ont
glissé jusqu'au fond de la carrière et
il va falloir ôter tous rock
le terrain est très mouillé glissant et
très dangereux il suffirait d'une
inclinaison horizontale d'un demi degré
pour dégringoler jusqu'en bas
il leur reste à peine quatre jours pour
fouiller la carrière c'est donc un recul
important pour faire de curry en temps
normal on serait en train d'exhumer des
ossements mais non on est encore en
train de creuser
mais avant de pouvoir déterrer des
ossements il leur faudra d'abord se
déterrer eux-mêmes
a mis la carrière grisée comme un œuf
sous le soleil brûlant tandis que DVD du
dinosaure à corne cherche les ossements
de ce qui pourrait être une nouvelle
espèce de dinosaure même au Canada la
chaleur peut devenir étouffante les
journées de 40 à 45 degrés Celsius ne
sont pas rares
mais ils sont dans leur élément car
l'image de leur mystérieux dinosaure se
précise enfin voilà une partie du
bouclier crânien c'est une section du
crâne de ce nouveau dinosaure à corne
ici on peut voir les eaux jumelées qui
forment les côtes de la collerette et en
remontant vers la partie arrière envoie
des petites bosses ces bosses marquent
l'emplacement d'énormes crochets
qui s'allongeait vers l'avant on n'a
jamais rien vu qu'il ressemble à ça mais
à quoi servait la collerette dessert à
topiens deux fonctions possibles ont été
envisagées les dinosaures à cornes sont
les seuls qui présentent ces énormes
collerettes décoratives à l'arrière du
crâne c'était peut-être une mesure de
protection imaginez un tricératops
attaqué par un T-Rex cette collerette
aurait protégé l'arrière de son cou
[Musique]
il semble que plusieurs cératopiens ne
pouvaient pas utiliser leur collerette
pour se défendre elles étaient trop
minces pour être vraiment utile alors à
quoi servait-elle on croit que c'est
large collerettes et leurs
ornementations permettaient aux animaux
de la même espèce de se reconnaître plus
facilement à la fin du Crétacé ces
forêts étaient envahis par des
dinosaures de toutes sortes ils devaient
avoir du mal à retrouver leur troupeau
ou leur compagnon
l'évolution des collerettes était
peut-être une simple affaire de
séduction
sur le site les paléontologues sont
pressés de découvrir d'autres fragments
clés du casse-tête tout va bien
jusqu'ici mais on espère pouvoir trouver
les cornes
[Musique]
de Philippe curry lutte pour remettre
son site en état les inondations ont
provoqué une énorme coulée de boue
déchargeant 10 tonnes de rock au fond de
la carrière et enfouissant les indices
qui auraient pu expliquer la mort d'un
troupeau entier de dinosaures en
arrivant au dernier jour d'une fouille
tout le monde soit disposé de beaucoup
plus de temps
pressé de rattraper le temps perdu
l'équipe creuse fébrilement le sol un
patiente d'exhumer d'autres eaux de
pachirino pourrait provenir d'un animal
de 10 animaux ou de n'importe quel
chiffre entre les deux
herbivores à visage cornus se
déplaçaient en immense troupeau
migratoire mais quelle force l'étale de
la nature a pu prendre des milliers de
dinosaures au piège sans leur laisser la
moindre chance de survie
après avoir passé plus d'une saison à
fouiller le dépôt d'ossement curry peut
éliminer deux scénarios entre autres on
a pu associer le dépôt d'ossement des
pachers rinaux au cendre volcanique ça
nous a suggéré l'hypothèse que les
volcans de l'époque produisaient
tellement de cendres qu'elles ont fini
par étouffer les animaux ce qui
expliquerait leur mort mais il n'y a pas
beaucoup de cendres dans le dépôt ce qui
rend cette hypothèse peu plausible
les feux de forêt présentaient une autre
possibilité on sait qu'ils étaient
fréquents et on a trouvé beaucoup de
charbon de bois dans certains dépôts
mais pas dans celui-là
c'est parce qu'on n'a pas trouvé de
réponse
dans le cas présent on a du mal à
comprendre pourquoi autant d'animaux
c'était rassemblés
rhinosaures ont à peine deux jours pour
trouver l'épreuve manquante dans
l'affaire non résolue de grandes
prairies
et à merveilleux
dinosaure à corne ont besoin d'un
dernier fossile pour identifier leur
dinosaure mystère avec un peu de chance
on trouvera les cornes ici
dans les Badlands de l'Alberta DVD
cherchent les cornes d'une espèce de
dinosaure encore inconnu
ce sera probablement la plus belle
découverte faite en Alberta depuis des
décennies
jusqu'ici les fouilles de pipes sont
Creek se sont soldés par un labeur
pénible et boueux de plus l'équipe des
pachirino n'a pas encore résolu le
mystère de la mort soudaine d'un vaste
troupeau de dinosaures
au bout de plusieurs jours d'un travail
éreintant les coéquipiers de curry ont
déposé leurs outils ils vont participer
à la soirée de levée de fonds de ce
dernier
c'est un événement formel en tenue de
soirée alors on va s'habiller très
élégamment enfin on fera de notre mieux
compte tenu du fait qu'on débarque d'un
site de fouille pour que oui les levées
de fonds représentent simplement un
moyen de financer ses fouilles et le bal
des dinosaures l'aidera à faire
connaître ses recherches et à obtenir
d'autres fonds pour son musée je
pourrais difficilement être plus près
pour ces étudiants c'est l'occasion de
se faire beau et de sortir un peu
puis d'un des fermiers me l'a prêté elle
a acheté chez Tiffany
[Musique]
dès que le bal des dinosaures est lancé
tous les invités peuvent enfin se
détendre et profiter de la fête
[Musique]
le lendemain matin habitué à manient une
pelle fait lance les travaux du musée
qui portera son nom
celui qui a donné son nom au musée
en réalité cette région est un véritable
terroir de dinosaures des forêts ont
poussé sur leurs ossements ce qui les
rend un peu plus difficiles à trouver
mais ceux qui savent chercher les
trouveront sans problème
mais Philippe n'a pas encore découvert
les causes de la mort d'un troupeau de
dinosaures à la fin du Crétacé et il ne
lui reste plus beaucoup de temps comme
n'importe quel enquêteur il a besoin de
preuves et il n'a plus qu'un jour pour
les trouver
[Musique]
l'équipe du dinosaure à corne de DVD
tente d'achever le portrait robot du
visage de l'animal afin de savoir si
elle a vraiment découvert une toute
nouvelle espèce de dinosaure
il y a beaucoup de scaniens dans cette
zone avec un peu de chance on trouvera
des cornes ici
la taille et l'emplacement des cornes
aideront les paléontologues à identifier
le mystérieux ceratopien
on a déjà exqué des vertèbres des côtes
des fragments de crâne et de membres
on en sait déjà beaucoup plus sur ce
dinosaure qu'on n'aurait jamais osé
l'espérer
mais on est encore à la recherche des
cornes pour reconstituer le visage de ce
nouveau dinosaure
sans les corner la collerette il n'y
aura pas de nouvelles espèces dans le
carnet de chasse de DVD David et de son
équipe par contre un pabson Quick la
tempête qui a failli tuer les
paléontologues leur fournira peut-être
l'indice manquant c'est peut-être ce qui
est arrivé aux dinosaure regroupés dans
la carrière
du dinosaure à cornes en sont à l'étape
finale de leur périple pour reconstituer
le visage d'une nouvelle espèce de
dinosaure ce n'est qu'une question de
temps on obtiendra tous les fragments
nécessaires mais à quoi ressemblera ce
nouveau dinosaure
entre temps à Paris c'est la dernière
journée de fouilles de Philippe curry et
de l'équipe des pachirino
quelle force l'étale de la nature a bien
pu tuer des milliers de bachirés ici
même il y a 73 millions d'années
la grande quantité d'osmante trouvée au
même endroit nous indique que ces
animaux ils sont presque tous morts
instantanément
tout animal qui se déplace en groupe va
affronter des situations susceptibles de
causer la mort en masse du troupeau on a
qu'à étudier les animaux dans nos
environnements modernes pour réaliser
que ce genre de choses arrivent très
fréquemment en 1985 dans le nord du
Québec environ 10 000 caribous sont
morts en très peu de temps en l'espace
de quelques heures c'est un exemple
parmi tant d'autres en notant que je
sache les bachirinosaures dont on a
trouvé les eaux dans ce dépôt se sont
sans doute noyés c'est la meilleure
explication parce que c'est la plus
simple
tandis que le vaste troupeau cherche une
nouvelle source de nourriture il est
pris dans la tempête prêt à tout pour
échapper à la montée soudaine des eaux
les pachirinaux tentent de traverser une
puissante rivière en crue ces dinosaures
étaient peut-être dans un système où les
eaux ont monté trop vite pour eux ils
ont paniqué et ils se sont mis à se
bousculer et à se noyer l'un l'autre
le troupeau de dinosaures de 4 tonnes a
perdu pied les animaux se sont retrouvés
dans les eaux agitées incapables de
nager puis de respirer
les dinosaures de ce dépôt d'osmans sont
associés aux Eaux-Vives et les eaux
vives les ont englouti
[Musique]
en exposant des milliers de carcasses
ce dépouille ont été dévorés par les
tyrannosaures puis elles sont restées
enfouies sous la poussière du temps
pendant 73 millions d'années
il semble incroyable qu'une seule
inondation est plus dissimée un troupeau
d'un millier d'animaux vigoureux
mais après avoir essuyé une violente
tempête fait de pruris et son équipe
connaissent maintenant la force d'une
union soudaine et sa puissance mortelle
[Musique]
cette année les coulées de bout et la
pluie torrentielle l'ont écourté les
fouilles l'équipe de Philippe curry sait
qu'elle a à peine gratté la surface de
ce terrain gorgé d'ossement
ami km de là l'équipe de DVD DaVinci
couvre de plâtres les ossements qu'ils
ont tiré des bas de l'âne
on a retrouvé des fragments essentiels
de collerette on a aussi un fragment de
la corne nasale et on a même pu
récupérer une des cordes frontales fixée
au-dessus des yeux un des trésors
concombre
c'est facile représente sans doute notre
plus importante trouvaille de la saison
ici c'est le centre du crâne la ligne
médiane
on peut voir qu'il y avait une pique ou
un crochet un peu plus bas
on les voit mieux de l'autre côté on a
donc deux crochets un de chaque côté de
la tête ils avaient la taille de ma main
j'ai l'impression que ce fragment
complétera les autres sections de
collerette
qu'on a déjà au labo
et qu'on pourra enfin reconstituer une
première collerette pour cette nouvelle
espèce de dinosaure
si les fragments de collerette Concorde
des aura découvert une toute nouvelle
espèce de sératopia
[Musique]
plusieurs mois s'écouleront avant que
David puisse déballer ses trésors dans
le laboratoire du Musée royal de
l'Ontario
ici les ossements du dinosaure inconnu
seront extirpés des vestes de plâtres
qui les protègent
lorsque in est en train de préparer
représente la section centrale arrière
de la collerette c'est l'os qui nous
permet d'affirmer avec certitude qu'il
s'agit d'une nouvelle espèce de
dinosaure
l'opération est délicate
un faux mouvement pourraient détruire
des mois de travail mais finalement le
précieux fragments de collerette émerge
le plus excitant ce sont les ornements
bien développés en forme de crochet qui
sont présents des deux côtés
si ce fragment de collerette correspond
aux spécimens recueillies durant les
dernières fouilles de David il dévoilera
les premières traces du visage d'une
nouvelle espèce
c'est vraiment extraordinaire
c'est confirmé
grâce aux fragments qu'on a découvert
l'an dernier
on a pu rassembler tous nos vestiges et
se faire une idée très nette de
l'apparence du dinosaure
notre artiste a donc pu créer une image
qui doit ressembler assez près à ce
nouveau dinosaure vous voulez le voir
le voilà
c'est la première reconstruction du surf
side cervitation le siratopsien du sud
de l'Alberta on n'a pas encore nommé
mais ici on voit bien ses crochets
courbés vers le bas à l'arrière de la
collerette il y a aussi de longues
cornes au dessus des yeux notre
dinosaure semble avoir été pourvu d'une
longue corne nasale qui est assez
inattendue
grâce à cet OS et à la reconstitution
complète de l'ornementation de la
collerette de ce dinosaure à corne on
peut confirmer l'existence d'une
nouvelle espèce et l'ajouter au
répertoire des dinosaures
chaque nouvelle espèce de dinosaure nous
en apprend davantage sur la diversité de
la vie antérieure de la planète Terre
en prime on va s'amuser à rédiger la
description complète de l'animal et à
lui trouver un nom
le dinosaure son nom sera exposé ici
même au musée en montant une nouvelle
exposition
j'essaie de me souvenir du temps où
j'étais un gamin de 5 ou 6 ans
absolument fou des dinosaures qu'est-ce
qui m'aurait impressionné je crois que
la possibilité de voir une nouvelle
espèce tout de suite après sa découverte
impressionnerait n'importe quel
paléontologue en herbe
[Musique]
est devenu chasseur de dinosaures pour
ressentir l'excitation d'une nouvelle
découverte et pour voir revivre une
créature préhistorique dans toute sa
splendeur
dans le prochain épisode de sur la piste
des dinosaures une jeune paléontologue
cherche la dernière pièce d'un
casse-tête mythique dans les bas de
lasses de l'Alberta on n'a pas retrouvé
la tête ou la massucodale mais je me
contenterai de savoir à quel endroit on
l'a trouvé il pourrait y rester des
choses intéressantes ils arrivent à
résoudre mystère vieux d'un siècle il
trouveront peut-être les ossements
manquants d'un dinosaures ayant vécu il
y a 74 millions d'années
et sur un site secret de la
Colombie-Britannique
un couple de paléontologue a découvert
le premier dinosaure complet de la
province couché à l'endroit même de sa
mort aucune route ne mène au site il
faut tout transporter par voie des airs
ils ont pu le sortir du sol mais ce
qu'ils pourront le faire voler
inquiet et très anxieux
[Musique]
c'est la saison des dinosaures
en ce moment les plus grands
paléontologues de la planète fouillent
le territoire canadien pour découvrir un
monde disparu depuis des millions
d'années
on a nos dinosaures ils combattront la
chaleur les inondations et le temps en
cherchant les traces des dinosaures
et les plus extraordinaires créatures
jamais vu sur terre revivrons bientôt
car nous marchons sur la piste des
dinosaures
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans cet épisode de sur la piste des
dinosaures une nouvelle génération de
chasseurs de dinosaures cherchent à
retrouver des fossiles disparus depuis
longtemps on cherche un animal
particulier l'ankylosaure qu'on appelle
souvent le dinosaure blindé si l'équipe
de longkylosaure arrive à résoudre
mystère vieux d'un siècle en assorti un
gros objet d'ici elle trouvera peut-être
les OSS moments quand deux dinosaures
ayant vécu il y a 77 millions d'années
et sur un site secret de la Colombie
Britannique
a découvert le premier dinosaure complet
de la province
coucher à l'endroit même de sa mort
aucune route ne mène au site il faut
tout transporter par voie des airs
l'équipe de landrezor a pu le sortir du
sol mais est-ce qu'elle pourra le faire
voler on sera inquiet inquiet très
anxieux
[Musique]
le dégel printanier tarde toujours en
Alberta et le mois de mai est déjà
avancé lorsque l'équipe de jeunes
scientifiques de l'Université de
l'Alberta arrive enfin au parc
provincial d'anne-soeur
la saison de la chasse aux dinosaures
est ouverte les étudiants seront dirigés
par le paléontologue canadien renommé le
chercheur Philippe Jake quand on
s'approche des Badlands et surtout quand
on arrive au sommet de la crête l'équipe
voit ces terres défilé sous ses yeux
éblouis l'excitation devient alors très
intense ce chasseur de fossiles de
renommée internationale a passé sa
carrière sur le terrain sur des sites de
fouilles établis un peu partout du
Montana à la Mongolie il a établi un
lien entre les dinosaures à plumes et
les oiseaux modernes éprouvaient que les
tyrannosaures chassaient en meute
revient fouiller son territoire natal si
je suis revenu encore une fois au parc
d'anneessor c'est parce que c'est le
meilleur site de la planète
la position du parc est idéale
il y a 75 millions d'années c'était une
forêt luxuriante un foyer humide et
fertile parfaitement adapté aux
douzaines d'espèces de dinosaures
herbivores dont des douzaines d'espèces
de dinosaures carnivores faisaient
régulièrement leur repas
c'est plutôt joli vu d'ici c'est vrai
c'est à l'envers non ce voyage
permettrait à Philippe Curie de jouer
son rôle de mentor auprès d'une nouvelle
génération de chasseurs de dinosaures si
je peux faire quelque chose de
gratifiant pour eux alors j'ai
l'impression d'avoir bien travaillé
comme les fonds recueillis financent à
peine trois semaines de fouilles chaque
jour compte pour deux
[Musique]
l'étudiant Scott personne est à la
recherche de carnivore l'an dernier j'ai
trouvé si dans tyrannosaure en un jour
et cette année je vais faire de mon
mieux pour briser mon record
ça me rappelle le jeudi parachute de
l'école primaire
l'étudiante Victoria se passionne pour
la paléontologie depuis son adolescence
les dinosaures depuis l'enfance ou
presque et ses fouilles dans le parc
provincial dinosaure c'est l'équivalent
de l'Acadie
il y a environ un siècle on a découvert
les premiers fossiles de dinosaure ancré
dans la brupte paysages lunaires des
Badlands
vers 1910 l'aventurier et chasseur de
fossiles burnum Brown a fait les
manchettes avec un squelette de
tricératops et le premier squelette de
tyrannosaure jamais découvert
un siècle plus tard cette nouvelle
génération d'explorateurs est résolue à
faire ses propres découvertes
compte tenu de la surface interne il
s'agit probablement d'un herbivore
cherche un herbivore bien précis
j'aime les ankylosaures les dinosaures
blindés parce qu'ils sont très laids et
à cause de leur laideur je crois qu'ils
n'ont pas la renommée qu'il mérite il
n'était peut-être pas beau mais ils
étaient coriace les ankylosaures étaient
les chars d'assaut du monde dinosauriens
leur corps massifs étaient couvert de
placocheuses qui les protégeait comme le
font celle des crocodiles et des tattoo
moderne
[Musique]
77 millions d'années plus tard Victoria
est sur la piste d'un seul en
philosophes elle cherche les eaux
manquants d'un squelette découvert dans
les Badlands il y a 100 ans
on cherche un animal en particulier le
NH est muker 5.61 ils ont été trouvés il
y a près de 100 ans par un homme appelé
William catler toute l'armure est encore
en place et on voit même des empreintes
de peau
d'âneur amateur de fossiles qui les
égarés régulièrement en plus de négliger
de documenter ces sites de fouilles
c'est génial de découvrir la tête ou la
masticodale mais je me contenterai de
retrouver l'endroit où il a été exhumé
est ici pour terminer son travail mais
elle aura du mal à trouver la grotte du
paléontologue amateur je me suis collé
la main sur un cactus
de montagne j'aimerais bien avoir les
gènes d'une chèvre
[Musique]
à 1000 km au nord-ouest une deuxième
chasse aux dinosaures est en cours
3300 personnes vivent à Tom Bridge en
Colombie-Britannique
il n'y a pas grand chose dans le coin à
part des ruisseaux du charbon et des
forêts inexplorées mais il gagne
quinzaine d'années des habitants sont
tombés par hasard sur des vestiges de
dinosaures ils ont fait venir des
experts
qui ne sont jamais repartis Richard
McRay et sa collègue Lisa Baclet qui
sont aussi mari et femme ont bâti leur
carrière en marchant sur la piste des
dinosaures chaque été ils explore ces
montagnes à la recherche de traces de
dinosaures c'est comme une chasse au
trésor au détour de chaque coude on ne
sait pas ce qu'on va trouver enfin je
voulais déjà devenir paléontologue alors
quand j'ai su qu'il y avait des vestiges
de dinosaures ici en
Colombie-Britannique j'étais plutôt
excité les traces de pas les traces de
pas
des grosses races de pas on a la partie
arrière du pied ici puis un orteil
latéral
l'orteil du milieu et l'orteil latérale
du côté opposé comme les doigts de pied
sont assez ronds à l'extrémité et il
s'agissait peut-être d'un gros ornithop
les Ornithopodes de gros herbivores
dotés de trois orteils sont considérés
comme les vaches du monde dinosaurien
ils ont laissé de profondes empreintes
de pas préservées dans la boue durcie et
pétrifiée au fil des siècles
en explorant ses collines pendant 10 ans
rituel McRay Lisa Buckley ont trouvé
assez de tracé de fossiles pour remplir
un entrepôt complet
ils ont donc réquisitionné un bâtiment
abandonné et ils l'ont rempli de
fossiles
primaire désaffectée
petit à petit il est facile partielle
découverts dans la région ont été
acheminés vers le nouveau musée voici
une découverte importante très peu de
traces entières de tyrannosaure ont été
retrouvés sur la planète aucun des
squelettes complets n'a été trouvé en
Colombie britannique mais avec un peu de
chance cette malheureuse situation
changera bientôt
[Musique]
au fond des forêts qui bordent les deux
paléontologues ont découvert le premier
squelette de dinosaure complet jamais
exhumé en Colombie Britannique ils ont
investi 5 années de travail mais
aujourd'hui le squelette va enfin
émerger du sol c'est un adrosa de 74
millions d'années un herbivore mesure en
9 mètres du museau à la queue et pesant
5,6 tonnes
étendue sur le sol on a un segment
proximal assez lent de la queue de
l'animal
cet échantillon pèse de 700 à 800 kg
un fossile n'est pas seulement un os
enseveli quand un dinosaure est
recouvert de sable des minéraux
s'infiltrent dans son squelette leur
rendant aussi dur et aussi lourd que
l'Europe c'est pour ça que notre
adrosaur pèse encore de 2 à 3000 kg
aucune route ne mène au site il faudra
donc le transporter par voie des airs et
on aura besoin d'un hélicoptère assez
performant
après tout on va ramener le premier
squelette complet de dinosauriens de la
Colombie Britannique
très court mais ce sera ma mission la
plus terrifiante à ce jour sur le site
et je me suis déjà suspendue à des
surfaces verticales avec des cordes pour
observer des traces de dinosaures
on sera inquiet inquiet très anxieux on
va se ranger les ongles mais si tout le
monde fait bien son travail notre
squelette attirera en un seul morceau
réussiront-ils à transporter l'adrésor
de 74 millions d'années sans accident ou
leur rêve d'exposer un dinosaure local
dans leur musée se brisera-t-il en
miettes
entre-temps l'équipe de l'ankylosaure a
peut-être découvert une image qui
l'amènera à la grotte de Williams nous
sommes sur la bonne voie
britannique l'équipe de la Resort est
enfin prête à exhumer un dinosaure qui
hiberne depuis très longtemps sa veste
de plâtre ne résistera peut-être pas
tandis que dans les Badlands de
l'Alberta au parc provincial l'équipe de
l'ankylosaure explore les rochers à la
recherche de fossiles mais Victoria ne
s'intéresse qu'à un seul dinosaure
à cause de sa queue très spéciale qui
pouvait servir de massues ou de âge de
guerre d'une simple oscillation cette
massucodale pouvait briser un os ou
fracasser le crâne avec une force
mortelle
et si la légende de ne ment pas un
ankylosaure pourrait bien attendre la
paléontologue de l'autre côté de cette
rivière
le mystère que l'équipe de Philippe
curry veut éclaircir et vieux d'un
siècle c'est un vulgaire
au début du 20ème siècle des
paléontologues américains ont envahi
cette région pour épiller une grande
quantité d'eau de dinosaures cela n'a
guère plus aucun indien le gouvernement
d'Ottawa a donc embauché son propre
chasseur de dinosaure Charles
un paléontologue qui recueillait des
fossiles dans l'ouest américain depuis
des dizaines d'années starburg et ses
trois fils se sont rendus en Alberta
pour rivaliser avec le chasseur de
fossiles américains
vers les dinosaures
ils étaient prêts à tout pour
revendiquer les découvertes les plus
importantes il n'y a aucun doute
là-dessus
brownberg se sont bien amusés à l'époque
le matériel c'est rodé depuis des
centaines de milliers d'années et
beaucoup de fossiles étaient déposés en
surface
grâce au stonebug un grand nombre des
faciles albertin sont restés au Canada
on peut les admirer au Musée royal de
l'Ontario à Toronto
mais la ruée vers les dinosaures avaient
aussi attiré beaucoup d'amateurs qui
espérait tirer une fortune de ces vieux
ossements l'un d'eux est à Welling et
katler l'homme qui a exhumé le squelette
complet d'un ankylosaure dans une grotte
locale mais peu après sa découverte deux
précieux fossiles l'os de la queue et le
crâne ont disparu mystérieusement avec
les coordonnées du site de fouilles ce
spécimen est présentement exposé à
Londres en Angleterre et on aimerait
récupérer les éléments manquants
pour aider Victoria un peu à les
retrouver Philippe curry a fait appel à
Darwin
de dinosaure
si quelqu'un sait où se trouve la
carrière ce sera
il observe tout rien lui échappe il voit
chaque trace laissé sur le terrain
parfois c'est une simple marque se rend
recherche ou peut-être un bout de
journal thank you du musée de
paléontologie
abandonnés et entraquant les ossements
disparus des dinosaures j'essaie de
retrouver ce site depuis très longtemps
mais je n'avais que la photocopie de
très mauvaise qualité d'une vieille
photo pour me guider par chance on a
récemment trouvé une copie originale de
la revue et j'ai maintenant une
meilleure image pour continuer mes
recherches la photo montre le fossile
pendant sa descente d'une carrière ce
qui donne au premier indice du paysage
environnant
en gros on cherche un endroit avec un
flanc de falaise vertical et une
infractuosité abrupte qui projette une
ombre l'emplacement exact représenté sur
la photo de cottleu n'a toujours pas été
identifié quand le était un
collectionneur amateur qui est venu au
Canada en 1898 vers 1912 il s'est mis à
collectionner les fossiles
est aussi devenu le seul représentant de
la race humaine qui était attaquée par
une ankylosaure pendant qu'il exhumait
le squelette est tombé sur lui en
blessant gravement la partie supérieure
de son corps ses compagnons ont
recueilli le reste du spécimen mais non
pas noté les coordonnées du site
listenberg André c'est une carte qui
documente tous les sites de fouilles de
l'époque elle pourrait guider l'équipe
vers la fameuse grotte de 4leux notre
campement est ici on va traverser la
rivière et se rendre à ce terrain plat
ou quand le avait établi son camp en
gros on remonte vers cette vallée
mais cette photo a été prise il y a plus
d'un siècle et pendant tout ce temps les
Badlands ont été constamment exposés au
vent et à la pluie même un expert comme
Tenka n'est pas certain de pouvoir
retrouver la grotte
entre-temps à quelques kilomètres de là
scraperson ça peut être arraché une dent
[Musique]
des profondeurs de la terre
ça c'est une dent de tyrannosaure elle
était placée à l'avant de la bouche du
tyrannosaure ils sont servaient pour
transpercer sa proie puis il arraché un
gros morceau de chair presque à
l'emporte-pièce
ce n'est pas un hasard si les
tyrannosaures étaient au sommet de la
chaîne alimentaire grâce à leur
puissance leur vitesse et leur sens
aiguisées c'est féroces bipède étaient
des prédateurs nés
scalperson a déjà découvert son premier
fossile de tyrannosaure la saison de
chasse s'annonce bonne
[Musique]
entre-temps attendre le Ridge en
Colombie-Britannique une équipe de
paléontologues formée des conjoints
articulé mais il craignent que leur site
de fou il ne soit détruit avant qu'il
parvienne à évacuer le dinosaure ça peut
sembler paranoïaque mais nos craintes
sont justifiées par le vandalisme que
d'autres sites ont subi
pour protéger le premier squelette de
dinosaure complet de la
Colombie-Britannique le couple n'a pas
divulgué les coordonnées du site il ne
veut prendre aucun risque aujourd'hui
à l'équipe de tournage jusqu'au site en
passant par un chantier secret
alors arrêtez de filmer
tandis que l'équipe de l'adrésor coupe
la caméra celle de l'ankylosaure
retrouve la piste de chasseurs de
dinosaures disparus depuis près d'un
siècle quand était assis à cet endroit
précis dans le parc provincial donneur
l'équipe de l'ankylosaure recherche un
site de fouilles disparu il y a un
siècle et qui pourrait contenir des
ossements depuis 77 millions d'années
cherche un animal en particulier celui
qu'on a appelé NH et Michael 5 1 6 1
entre temps dans un endroit secret un
squelette d'adressor de 74 millions
d'années à temps l'ambulance aérienne
qui doit l'évacuer en toute sécurité
l'équipe de paléontologues qu'il a
découvert fait le maximum pour protéger
le site des vandales l'équipe de
tournage doit donc voyager en aveugle et
ne pas filmer la route qui mène au site
[Musique]
bon nous sommes perdus dans les bois et
je parie que vous ne savez absolument
pas où vous êtes alors vous pouvez
filmer
oh oh
crier semble une étrange façon d'aborder
un emplacement secret mais cette mesure
de sécurité n'a rien à voir avec la
sécurité des fossiles elle protège
plutôt les humains on doit être prudent
car des ours utilisent ce sentier
le cric vous venez d'entendre et notre
système d'alerte anti-ours il leur
signale notre présence
ici on a des déjections d'ours des
déjections ce sont des excréments les
déjections c'est de la merde de la merde
des crottes des fesses
n'est pas venu sur le site depuis 6 mois
voilà le site on est très excité d'avoir
pu revenir ici cette année on espère
évacuer le dinosaure principal vous
voyez cette bosse c'est lui l'équipe
avait enterré l'énorme squelette pour le
protéger des vandales
à présent son équipe doivent l'exhumer
avant de le préparer pour son vol même
manier l'appel ne leur fait pas peur au
cours des cinq dernières années on a
probablement enlevé plus de 300 mètres
cubes de rock manuellement
il se libère
une fois la terre enlevée ils verront
comment leur dinosaure a supporté sa
longue hibernation
il a très bien supporté l'hiver la veste
de plâtre ne m'inquiète plus elle
survivra au transport non c'est faux je
vais mettre quand même mais la veste ne
sait pas détériorée depuis l'été dernier
le squelette complet d'un dinosaure
fossilisé se cache sous la veste de
plâtre couché à l'endroit où il a rendu
son dernier soupir comme vous le voyez
nous avons identifié différents segments
des eaux de l'animal
ces chevrons ou arkemo sont les eaux du
dessous de la queue et ici ce sont les
neurépines ou les pindorsales la
première série de vertèbres articulée
qu'on a retrouvé les bines dorsales du
dinosaure est courbé en sens inverse
comme s'il était mort violemment et très
douloureusement autrefois quand les
scientifiques ont commencé à interpréter
les fossiles on croyait que cette
position reflétait l'agonie de l'animal
mais le domaine a évolué et on a fini
par réaliser que pendant que le corps du
dinosaure se décomposait est tombé en
morceaux s'étendons et ses ligaments se
dessécher c'est ce phénomène qui
provoque la courbure inversée du cou et
de la queue
après avoir reposé sous terre pendant 74
millions d'années l'adresseur est prêt à
s'envoler vers son nouveau foyer mais
une question demeure réussira-t-il son
vol
dans les bas de l'Alberta l'équipe de
l'ankylosaure a appris que la grotte de
coteleur un site de fouilles disparu
depuis un siècle pourrait être de
l'autre côté de la rivière presque en
face de leur campement
l'expédition est dirigée par le chasseur
de dinosaures daron tanké qui est
peut-être déjà sur la bonne voie
on vient d'atteindre l'endroit où le
campement de kotleux était établi en
1914 sa tante était montée dans cette
zone là bas
c'est super
si tu restes près de moi tu verras que
les collines de la photo sont celles
qu'on voit là-bas
et cette colline surplombée de rochers
qui descendent aussi en pente c'est la
bonne c'est génial fantastique génial
après avoir retrouvé son campement
Thanki et l'équipe de l'ankylosaure se
séparent afin de chercher des indices
qui les mèneront à la grotte de catler
il y a un vieux fil rouillé ici sur
l'emplacement de sa tente c'était une
précaution supplémentaire pour s'assurer
que les caisses ne s'ouvriraient pas
pendant le transport en train il a
presque 100 ans
c'est un bon début j'ai réussi à trouver
le site de l'ancien campement de William
catler grâce à la photo prise en 1914
comme il n'avait ni camion ni voiture il
a dû camper près de la carrière nous
sommes sur la bonne piste
plus loin dans les bas de landes Scott
perceuse track le tyrannosaure mais il a
découvert quelque chose d'un peu moins
terrifiant en cours de route ce sont les
fragments d'un membre de tortues
marines préfèrent l'eau
c'était pas des tortues terrestres ce
qui prouve que l'environnement était
humide et chaud
il y a 75 millions d'années l'Alberta
bordel irrivent d'une chaudière
intérieure qui s'enfonçait profondément
dans le territoire nord-américain
la contrée était horrible des marées
de la végétation nécessaire aux
herbivores et dans ces mots peuplés des
herbivores nécessaires au carnivores
[Musique]
voilà le radius de adosaure un dinosaure
avec de canard sa forme nous le confirme
est assez gros bien plus gros que le
mien c'est évident cet animal devait
mesurer plus de 9 mètres de long de son
bec de canard jusqu'au bout de sa longue
queue le fossile de scrap pulsion
provient donna drosaure un dinosaure à
bec de canard c'était le plus gros
herbivore de l'Amérique du Nord ce qui
est vraiment fascinant c'est quand se
couche on partait on peut voir des
petits éraflures sur la surface de l'os
et aussi cette unique en taille très
profonde ce sont des marques de morsure
et le seul animal de l'écosystème du
parc d'agnosor capable de laisser une
entaille aussi profonde sur un os était
un membre de la famille des
tyrannosaures
il y a 75 millions d'années un
tyrannosaure connu sous le nom de
Gorgosaurus chassait dans cette région
l'animal mesurait 9 mètres de long et
pouvait atteindre une vitesse de 40 km à
l'heure
en 1913 le tout premier squelette de
Gorgosaurus a été découvert ici dans le
parc provincial par les premiers
paléontologues du Canada les Starbucks
a découvert un os qui vaut la peine
d'être ramené au camp mais il devra
avoir la délicatesse d'un artiste pour
l'extraire du sol sans le fracasser
de l'autre côté de la rivière Darwin
tanky et l'équipe de l'ankylosaure se
rapproche de l'emplacement mystérieux en
ce moment nous sommes à peu près ici
une carte de la région dressée par les
stonberg il y a 60 ans il croit qu'elle
le guide vers la grotte de 4h qui
pourrait contenir la massucodale et le
crâne manquant de l'ankylosaure le GPS
me donne des informations
contradictoires les flèches changent
constamment de position malheureusement
la vieille carte et les GPS de l'équipe
ne font pas bon ménage
on ne peut pas être sûr à 100% d'avoir
découvert le site on a aucune photo du
véritable site qui nous confirme son
emplacement
si la carte de Darwin tenki est exacte
elle conduit à l'équipe de l'ankylosaure
jusqu'à un site de fouilles abandonné
depuis 100 ans
tandis qu'en Colombie-Britannique
l'équipe de Land Rosa espère qu'elle
pourra tirer son fossile massif du sol
sans fracasser tous ses os jamais
transporté de dinosaures une autre
première sur un site de fouilles secret
de la Colombie Britannique l'équipe de
la drzor attend son transport elle
espère que l'hélicoptère sera assez
puissant pour soulever le squelette et
il l'emportait dans les airs on aura
besoin d'un hélicoptère performant et
dans les Badlands de l'Alberta Victoria
et l'équipe de l'ankylosaure affrontent
un territoire hostile dans l'espoir de
découvrir un site désaffecté depuis près
d'un siècle
s'il retrouve la légendaire grotte de
cutter il récupèreont peut-être la
massucodale et le crâne manquant d'un
précieux ankylosaure c'est fragments ont
disparu avant l'envoi du squelette à
Londres il y a environ un siècle comme
moi
on espère trouver ce qu'on cherche leur
sol véritable indice et la photo jaunit
qui reproduit peut-être le moment où le
squelette a été sorti de la carrière on
voit clairement l'inclinaison oui
on a sorti un gros objet d'ici quelque
chose d'assez gros mais quoi
on a trouvé des débris de jute de plâtre
et de bois on sait donc qu'on a sorti
quelque chose d'ici le rock ressemble à
celui qu'on voit autour du spécimen
exposé à Londres je ne vois pas pourquoi
quelqu'un aurait pris la peine d'exhumer
un objet dans cet endroit perdu
s'il ne s'agissait pas d'une découverte
significative
vous croyez qu'il y avait assez de place
on a l'article de 4 celui où il décrit
la taille du bloc en pied
j'ai à peu près 10 pieds
d'après moi la queue était là
il n'y a pas d'os
non
à mon avis la carrière devrait être plus
grande parce que le spécimen est énorme
l'équipe est déçue
a fait fausse route la grotte de 4
feuilles était sûrement plus grande que
celle-là je ne sais pas c'est une énigme
je suis très troublé par ce qui se passe
en ce moment
c'est vraiment dommage parce que
ce serait le dernier clou du cercueil
cette carrière est peut-être perdue pour
toujours elle a pu servir complètement
et disparaître tout simplement
tant qu'on aura pas retrouvé le crâne ou
une preuve formelle de l'emplacement de
la grotte de Canteleu on continuera les
recherches parce que ce mystère n'est
toujours pas résolu
de l'autre côté de la rivière reddeear
Scott piercing passe un meilleur moment
l'os da drosomes mordue par une
tyrannosaure est prêt à être exhumé
on utilise le papier absorbant
pour protéger les ossements
le plâtre protège les fossiles
fragilisés mais même quand ils sont
enveloppés ils peuvent encore se
fragmenter
c'est l'étape la plus dangereuse de
l'extraction
si tout va bien la veste tiendra le coup
mais on ne peut rien garantir alors
croisez les doigts
merveilleux c'est parfait
absolument parfait
je peux faire mes bagages et aller
manger un bon repas
[Musique]
attendre le Ridge en Colombie
Britannique l'équipe formée par Richard
McRay attend les résultats d'une
expertise professionnelle
un squelette d'adressor de 4000 kg
peut-il être transporté sans risque par
voie aérienne si on peut ajouter un peu
plus de puissance au moteur ça ne fera
pas de mal
présentement les paléontologues n'ont
aucune garantie de sécurité
tandis que l'équipe technique évalue la
charge ils attendent l'hélicoptère de
transport
l'approche de l'hélico génère des vents
de 170 km/h comme l'ouragan certains de
ses vents pourraient renverser ses
arbres très facilement
vous ne les verrez probablement pas mais
ils vont tomber raide et vous rompre le
coup alors je pense plus à moi qu'au
dinosaures
après tout il est déjà mort
malgré la longue attente rien ne
garantit le succès de l'entreprise il
s'agit du premier squelette de dinosaure
complet jamais trouvé en
Colombie-Britannique et même s'il
franchit la ligne des arbres en une
seule pièce il pourrait se fracasser en
plein vol sous l'effet de son propre
poids on devrait en mettre une ici et
une autre là
en le fossile quittera le sol et qu'il
n'aura aucune stabilité ce sera la
période la plus dangereuse et si quelque
chose lui arrivait on y peut rien même
si on y est attaché je vais mettre un
filet par dessus pour qu'il ne tournoi
pas pendant le vol le filet brisera le
vin
le dinosaure volera sur une distance
d'un kilomètre interminable avant d'être
déposé en douceur sur un camion à
plateforme
l'hélicoptère peut supporter une charge
utile de 5000 kg
a calculé que le fossile pesé environ
4400 kg un peu plus que l'éléphant
adulte mais ce n'est qu'une hypothèse
non vérifiée
j'ai beaucoup d'expérience
je n'ai jamais transporté de dinosaures
c'est une autre première
l'équipe technique a fabriqué un filet
de corde pour tirer l'adresseur du ravin
et le conduire en pleine lumière comme
attraction vedette du musée de temple
Ridge
mais tout dépend du bon déroulement de
ce transport aérien
un nouveau jour se lève sur le parc
provincial donneur
Victoria la grotte de Kotler ou
l'ankylosaure de ses rêves mais si elle
continue ses fouilles les bases lui
offriront peut-être un prix de
consolation
sur le terrain on trouve très rarement
les fossiles qu'on recherche à un moment
précis où qu'on espère trouver durant la
saison de fouilles une heure plus tard
sa ténacité est enfin récompensée
qu'as-tu trouvé Victoria ça c'est long
semble enfoncer dans le sol
on va gratter les deux côtés et voir ce
qui se produira le soleil très friable
il ne sera pas trop difficile à exhumer
génial
c'est toujours de trouver un entier
je cherche principalement des fossiles
d'ankylosor mais j'aime bien trouver
d'autres vestiges cette découverte m'a
rendu très heureuse
les nuages gris qui s'accumulent au
dessus des bas de l'âne n'assombriront
pas l'enthousiasme de la paléontologue
car elle vient de faire une découverte
significative il c'est vraiment
fantastique il a l'air en bon état super
je suis contente je crois qu'il s'agit
du tibia d'un dinosaure carnivore le
Gorgosaurus
c'est un parent du tyrannosaure plus
petit que celui que l'ensemble du public
connaît là-dedans que scotters
provient de la même espèce que le tibia
il y a 74 millions d'années le
Gorgosaurus parcourait les termes
marécageuses à la recherche derbivore
moins rapide que lui et l'adresseur
était sûrement sur son menu
même si c'est peu probable les deux
paléontologues auraient-ils découvert
les vestiges du même Gorgosaurus et du
même atroceau le prédateur et sa proie
[Musique]
Victoria a fait une étonnante découverte
mais elle doit maintenant battre Dame
Nature de vitesse
il nous reste environ une demi-heure
puis toutes ces rigoles vont se remplir
d'eau il y aura des cascades
substantielles et ces canaux seront
inondés il n'y aura plus moyen de se
déplacer
c'est un peu frustrant par chance on a
la belle trouvaille de Victoria
on aurait aimé protéger l'os un peu
mieux le mettre à l'abri de la pluie
le nouveau facile de Victoria est exposé
aux éléments pour la première fois
depuis des millions d'années mais
personne ne sait s'il sera encore là
demain en Colombie-Britannique un
hélicoptère transportera le squelette de
nadrosor mais si l'équipe de palet a mal
calculé son poids il n'ira pas bien loin
j'ai déjà vu des vestiges largués à 60
mètres du sol il n'en reste plus rien
attendre le Ridge en Colombie
Britannique un hélicoptère est en plein
vol il génère des vents aussi puissants
que l'ouragan s'il réussisse leur coup
le premier squelette de dinosaure
complet jamais découvert en Colombie
Britannique s'envolera vers son nouveau
foyer en Alberta le parc provincial est
inondé et Victoria Herber a trouvé un
précieux facile mais les fouilles ont
été interrompus par la pluie si elle ne
cesse pas des journées de labeur acharné
vont partir à la dérive notre journée
est perdue que ça nous plaise ou non la
pluie rend le territoire des Badlands
tellement glissant qu'on ne peut pas s'y
aventurer il faut rester ici et attendre
la fin
réussit quand même à se distraire à la
façon des chasseurs de dinosaures
j'ai hâte de voir les croquis des autres
et bien le voilà super
la pluie tombe sans répit mais au moins
les membres de l'équipe sont bien au
chaud et bien nourris
c'est frustrant parce qu'on veut sortir
et explorer le terrain mais la pluie et
la boue nous empêche de le faire en ce
moment les paléontologues ont une seule
option rester à l'abri et espérez que le
temps délire à bientôt
le jour du dinosaure
un hélicoptère est en route pour
transporter le premier squelette de
dinosaure articulé de la
Colombie-Britannique
avant le transport j'évalue toujours les
lieux d'atterrissage possible les
paléontologues riches MacRay et Lisa
Buckley attendent ce genre de puissance
ils sont morts d'inquiétude
je me suis déjà senti mieux un petit
moustique m'a piqué mais ce n'est rien
ne va pas trop bien non plus
je me sens mal j'ai mal à la gorge je
suis déshydraté je n'ai pas dormi je
n'ai pas mangé ça risque de mal finir
[Musique]
nos deux pilotes salut
les risques on pourrait avoir une panne
de moteur et être forcé de larguer la
charge mieux vaut ne pas en parler ça
n'arrivera sûrement pas mais ouais c'est
pas un rocher c'est sûrement plus
fragile que ça beaucoup plus fragile
[Musique]
l'hélicoptère est en place et les deux
paléontologues retournent à leur poste
près du fossile
j'entends le bruit des pâles la minute
de vérité j'ai hâte de le voir voler ce
sera tout un spectacle il n'a pas bougé
depuis 74 millions d'années et il risque
d'avoir tout un choc en s'envolant
le couple s'oppose une seule question le
poids du fossile a-t-il été bien évalué
s'il pèse plus de 5000 kilos le
transport aérien pourrait finir en
catastrophe j'ai déjà vu des vestiges
largués à 60 mètres du sol il le frappe
avec une telle force que le plâtre se
liquéfie à nouveau et il n'en reste plus
rien
le premier squelette de dinosaure
complet de la Colombie Britannique
arrivera-t-il la destination en une
seule pièce
nos deux paléontologues sont loin d'être
rassurés pendant que l'équipe de
l'ankylosaure attend la fin de l'orage
afin que Victoria Herber puisse aller
récupérer son précieux tibia de
Gorgosaurus
parce qu'on veut sortir et explorer le
terrain mais la pluie et la bonne nous
empêche de le faire
avec anxiété le premier essai de
l'hélicoptère qui doit soulever le
premier squelette de dinosaure complet
de la Colombie Britannique avant de le
transporter dans les airs
si le transport aérien réussit
l'adresseur deviendra le premier vestige
dinosaure vient complet de la province
[Musique]
devinez le poids de notre sort est au
jeu dangereux quand il doit se
transformer en dinosaure volant
a évalué qu'il peut environ 4400 kg s'il
s'est trompé les pilotes devront larguer
le fossile
[Musique]
au bout de plusieurs minutes d'une
attente insupportable ils ont enfin des
nouvelles des pilotes on vient de
confirmer le poids de la veste de plâtre
et la charge est de
400400 kg super bien calculer
[Musique]
à peine 600 kg de moins que la charge
limite pouvez-vous nous prévenir quand
il atterrira sur la plateforme du camion
s'il vous plaît
ça y est il a atterri en douceur il a
atterri c'est terminé
ouais cette nuit dormirai comme Loire
j'ai été très heureux de voir notre
vestige sur la remorque et dans une très
belle position c'était fantastique pour
moi ça vaut bien dit Noël
en Alberta la pluie a enfin cessé et
l'équipe de l'ankylosaure peut retourner
dans les bas de l'Inde en toute sécurité
c'est la dernière journée de Victoria
erber au campement et elle espère que
son facile à survécu à la pluie
[Musique]
est intacte et encore bien ancré dans le
grès
maintenant je dois écoper l'eau creuser
sous le tibia et lui mettre sa veste de
plâtre
en rentrant Victoria ramènera l'os d'un
Gorgosaurus le prédateur le plus
terrifiant du parc provincial un
dinosaure de la même espèce que celui
qui a rouge et l'os da drozor de
scotters
[Musique]
en restant ouvert on finit toujours par
récupérer un trésor
être une branche dans cette veste
l'os de Gorgosaurus est prêt à voyager
Victoria doit maintenant dire au revoir
au Badlands elle n'a pas réussi à
retrouver la grotte de 4 ni son
précieuse ankylosaures mais chaque
expédition de fouille apporte ses
propres récompenses la paléontologie est
un domaine où il faut travailler Dieu et
longtemps si on trouve quoi que ce soit
c'est déjà une belle réussite
je suis très heureuse d'avoir eu la
chance d'explorer de nouveaux sites
potentiels et même si on n'a pas trouvé
ce qu'on cherchait je suis satisfaite de
ce qu'on a trouvé je pense que mon
expédition sur le terrain est réussi
[Musique]
entre temps attendre
enfin à son nouveau foyer
on va dégager le squelette
nettoyer tous ces eaux le rendre
présentable et en faire l'attraction
principale de notre galerie
il leur faudra du temps et beaucoup
d'efforts pour préparer l'exposition
Mélissa Bacri mettront tout leur cœur la
chasse aux fossiles est l'une des
dernières frontières inexplorées de
l'Amérique du Nord on peut encore y
faire sa marque aller dans des coins aux
personnes a mis les pieds et y trouver
des vestiges encore jamais vues
de dinosaures complets en
Colombie-Britannique et continueront
donc de scruter des parois rocheuses et
d'explorer les ruisseaux à la recherche
de leurs prochaines grandes découvertes
dans le prochain épisode de sur la piste
des dinosaures de l'océan à l'autre des
paléontologues escalades des falaises
friables et affront démarrer implacable
afin de trouver les vestiges des
premiers dinosaures de la planète si ces
chasseurs de dinosaures atteignent les
ossements avant qu'il ne soit emportés
par les vagues il découvriront certaines
des plus anciennes espèces de dinosaures
ayant foulé le sol de la terre
[Musique]
c'est la saison des dinosaures
en ce moment les plus grands
paléontologues de la planète fouillent
le territoire canadien pour découvrir un
monde disparu depuis des millions
d'années
et les combattront la chaleur les
inondations et le temps en cherchant les
traces des dinosaures
et les plus extraordinaires créatures
jamais vu sur terre revivrons bientôt
car nous marchons sur la piste des
dinosaures
dans cet épisode de sur la piste des
dinosaures deux équipes vont affronter
les marées montantes de la baie de Fundy
en Nouvelle-Écosse en cherchant
l'origine des dinosaures
sur les rives du bassin dominance
l'équipe des chasseurs d'empreintes doit
retrouver les traces des premiers
dinosaures qui ont parcouru la terre
avant que leur fossiles ne soit emporté
par la marée c'est vraiment dommage de
ne pas pouvoir rapporter ça dans mes
bagages
tandis qu'aua si l'équipe des projets
peut atteindre ses fossile avant qu'il
ne soit englouti par la mer
on ne peut pas arrêter la marée elle
pourrait découvrir une nouvelle espèce
de dinosaure ayant survécu à un
cataclysme planétaire ces animaux sont
les survivants
notre poursuite des plus anciens
dinosaures du Canada commencent dans la
baie de Fundy en Nouvelle-Écosse
ici les falaises qui surplombent
l'Atlantique existent depuis des
centaines de millions d'années les
marées côtières y sont les plus hautes
du monde ce qui représente une
bénédiction et une malédiction pour les
chasseurs de dinosaures
elles compliquent un navigation près de
la plage mais elle provoque une forte
érosion très profitable au paléontologue
le chercheur team fidac ses spécialisé
dans la chasse aux fossiles des
dinosaures les plus anciens de la terre
il dirige une équipe qui creusera au
plus profond des sols de gré rouge de
wash and black
en passant vous êtes embauché
l'équipe de teenfi dag devra travailler
rapidement ceci est sous l'eau pendant
une bonne partie de l'année mais cette
fois les marées seront basse pendant 10
jours
des pelles des râteaux de dangereuses
instruments destruction on ne doit pas
creuser de trop grands trous tout le
contenu compte pourra pas recueillir
pendant ce cours délais sera emporté par
la marée montante on ne peut pas arrêter
la marée
et son équipe cherche les ancêtres les
célèbres dinosaures à long cou
les prosopropodes ces créatures font
partie des premiers dinosaures
terrestres qui ont évolué pendant la
période du Trias il n'y a plus de 200
millions d'années
le tyrannosaure était plus proche de
notre ère que de celle des prosopodes ce
carnivore a vécu il y a 66 millions
d'années mais pour retourner à l'époque
des projets repodes il faudrait remonter
le temps 134 millions d'années plus tôt
aujourd'hui tu es une fille DAC va
peut-être nommer une nouvelle espèce de
des dinosauresiens les plus anciens de
la planète
on recueille des fossiles sur ce site
depuis 17 ans on a identifié un nombre
important de spécimens et il semble bien
que ce soit une nouvelle espèce de pose
au mois 12 espèces de prosopopodes ont
été répertoriés mais les scientifiques
croient qu'en réalité il y en avait bien
davantage le nouveau genre de pros
européropodes de la baie de Fundy
pourrait bientôt se joindre à la liste
des espèces depuis la dernière visite du
paléontologues des tonnes de débris ont
recouvert le site
et voilà c'est parfait
mais s'ils veulent trouver des ossements
ils devront éviter les éboulements
société dangereux vous ne devez jamais
l'oublier je ne veux pas qu'il y ait un
seul blessé l'équipe est prête à prendre
des risques pour découvrir un nouvel
élément du passé
ce serait très excitant de trouver un
site de nidification ou des crânes on
espère toujours faire la découverte de
notre vie
mais pour prouver l'existence d'une
nouvelle espèce de projets
de l'autre côté de la baie tu as le chat
remonte encore plus loin en arrière car
il est sur la piste de dinosaures plus
anciens que les pros européropodes
j'ai toujours dit que les paléontologues
sont des gamins qui n'ont jamais vieilli
faire le chat est l'un des
paléontologues du musée géologique de
Fundy
en ce moment il est scrute et rive du
bassin de ménage à la recherche des
premiers dinosaures de la terre
mais contrairement à la plupart de ses
collègues il s'intéresse plus au rocher
qu'aux ossements
il s'arrête d'abord à pas d'Island un
endroit où personne n'a chassé le
dinosaure depuis plus de 20 ans
du Trias
très excitant
ça ce sont sûrement les vestiges de
Paddy's Island mais on a de la chance
d'après moi toute cette dorsale devrait
être lisse et plate
et son collègue Neven down fouilleront
une zone qui est sous l'eau pendant la
plus grande partie de l'année
mais en réfluence la marée expose une
zone paradisiaque pour un chasseur de
dinosaures
sur terre très peu d'endroits ont gardé
la trace des premiers dinosaures et la
Nouvelle-Écosse est l'un de ces sites
privilégiés aujourd'hui l'équipe des
chasseurs d'empreintes ne cherchent pas
les ossements mais d'autres vestiges
quand on voit des rochers bien plats on
sait qu'on a de meilleures chances de
trouver des empreintes de dinosaures
j'adore les empreintes on peut les
observer quand il y en a deux on a du
mouvement si on les compare aux images
d'un film chaque empreinte est une image
et en collant toutes ces images ensemble
on peut repasser la vie d'un dinosaure
en boucle un animal peut laisser des tas
d'empreintes durant sa vie mais il ne
laissera comme ce squelette un squelette
et le sous-produit d'une créature morte
mais ses empreintes sont les
sous-produits de sa vie
malheureusement le mouvement continuel
de la marée est rode s'est rocher
aucune trace de dinosaures
si tu as le choix découvre des
empreintes sur ce site elles
appartiendront à certaines des plus
anciennes créatures de la terre
et elles auront vécu ici
les fossiles découvert le long des rives
de la baie de Fundy appartiennent à une
période importante de l'histoire de la
Terre il y a 200 millions d'années les
continents terrestres étaient rassemblés
en un énorme bloc continental la Pangée
la Nouvelle Écosse actuelle était située
dans son centre torride la planète était
très chaude et les reptiles les
régnaient en maître mais le foyer humide
de les premiers dinosauresiens à la
disparaître
détruit par le cataclysme géologique qui
a refait le monde
on peut encore voir des traces de cette
transformation catastrophique dans les
falaises de la baie de Fundy
et nul ne les comprend mieux que Paul
aussen qui a fait une première
découverte significative sur ce site en
falaise de basalte ancien le basalte est
une sorte de la volcanique durcie
semblable à ce qu'on voit en Islande de
nos jours
mais ici elle renferme l'épreuve de la
plus grande extinction de masse de toute
l'histoire de la Terre
des dinosaures a été marquée par deux
extinctions massives la première a eu
lieu au début de leur règne et la
deuxième Miami fin pour toujours
l'extinction de masse du Trias a
commencé par la fracture de la Pangée
déclenchée par des éruptions de volcan
probablement situées au Maroc un proche
voisin de la Nouvelle-Écosse à l'époque
ces éruptions volcaniques étaient d'une
ampleur incroyable plus destructrice
qu'aucun humain n'a jamais connu
ces éruptions ont duré des milliers
d'années la lave a recouvert une zone de
la taille des États-Unis et la Nouvelle
Écosse a été ensevelie sous un magma de
roche en fusion
d'énormes quantités d'une lave semblable
à celle qui a formé ses falaises ce sont
déversées sur la contrée anéantissant
toute vie sur leur passage et libérant
d'énormes quantités de gaz carbonique et
de soufre au bout du compte ce désastre
à provoquer l'extinction de 50 à 75% de
toute la vie animale et végétale de la
terre
les projets robots qui avaient survécu à
l'extinction massive du Trias ont dû
affronter un monde dévasté
et survivre dans un pays calciné en
tirant à grand peine leur nourriture des
maigres restent de la végétation
l'équipe des projets repodes cherche des
preuves de leur survie dans les
ossements de wash and bluff
c'est un site unique dans tout le Canada
l'Amérique du Nord et même le monde
entier car il correspond à une période
très particulière
l'extinction massive de la fin du Trias
ces animaux étaient les survivants c'est
vraiment ici qu'on pourra voir l'aube
des dinosaures
mais s'il ne récupère pas les vestiges
j'attends la baie de Fundy reprendra ses
spécimens anciens depuis deux jours
l'équipe retire la couche supérieure de
débris d'érosion
mais comme elle dispose de quelques
jours à peine pour identifier une
nouvelle espèce de projets
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé
magnifique je crois que tu viens de
découvrir notre dépôt d'ossement Jack
merci beaucoup
ça c'est une vertèbre de proseuropodes
on envoie que la face postérieure
elle est enfouie depuis 200 millions
d'années c'est la première fois qu'elle
remonte à l'air libre
c'est une découverte importante pour
vous c'est important ouais
tu me fais là qu'a découvert son premier
fossile il appartient à une créature qui
est née et morte 134 millions d'années
avant le tyrannosaure et le tricératops
et 200 millions d'années avant
l'apparition des humains
cet animal mesurait de 3 à 4 mètres de
long cette vertèbre est au bout de sa
queue on a donc beaucoup de travail
devant nous si elle est seule il y aura
sûrement d'autres éléments isolés dans
le coin il faudra dégager tous les
débris d'érosion et trouver un moyen de
recueillir les ossements
le chercheur a découvert le bout de la
queue d'un animal et s'il a de la chance
il trouvera son crâne à l'autre
extrémité
deux équipes affrontent les marées
montantes de la baie de Fundy
à Watson bluff l'équipe des projets pour
identifier une nouvelle espèce de
dinosaure on se croise les doigts notre
véritable objectif est de découvrir un
crâne de pros européens
fait de l'escalade pour traquer certains
des plus anciens dinosaures de la
planète
cela signifie que ce sont les ancêtres
de toute la vie terrestre
en nouvelle-école sur les plages du
bassin de ménage dans la baie de Fundy
l'équipe des chasseurs d'empreintes
cherche les traces de certains des plus
anciens dinosaures de la planète c'est
vraiment très excitant
entre-temps Hawa senlov l'équipe des
projets pop de timfi DAQ a trouvé le bon
philo bingo j'ai trouvé mais elle
devrait affronter une marée montante qui
pourrait bien réclamer son trésor
pour l'équipe des projets repodes la
descente de la falaise constitue le plus
court chemin vers le site de fouilles
[Musique]
il y a 200 millions d'années cette
région était complètement dévastée
[Musique]
un cataclysme volcanique avait anéanti
une grande partie de la vie sur Terre et
pourtant de nombreux membres du groupe
des prosopodes avait réussi à survivre à
cet endroit
tout ce qu'on a découvert ici a été
trouvé au-dessus des basaltes de North
Mountain qui correspondent au début de
la période jurassique
l'équipe des projets repas espère que
ces ossements leur permettront de
comprendre comment ces dinosaures ont pu
survivre des astres mais aussi
d'apprendre ces appartiennent à une
nouvelle espèce encore inconnue les
paléontologues ont découvert un
fragmente que mais ils ont à peine
quelques jours pour vérifier si le crâne
se trouve à l'autre extrémité
le crâne et le vrai trésor caché c'est
lui qui nous permettra d'identifier le
dinosaure et qui répondra à nos
questions sur son espèce
les deux premiers jours on a creusé le
sol sans trouver grand chose mais en ce
moment on progresse assez rapidement
en cherchant des eaux on a découvert un
vestige en forme de plaque la partie
inférieure d'une mâchoire probablement
il n'y a pas de dents pour confirmer mon
hypothèse mais la forme correspond
repérez des vestiges enfouis depuis 200
millions d'années représente un grand
défi mais au début de sa carrière
TEnfida qui était sculpteur et
illustrateur médical et il peut
reconnaître un os en trois dimensions
même six pieds sous terre si vous voulez
bien descendre je vous apprendrai à
reconnaître cette os
imaginez qu'un être vivant a été ici il
y a 200 millions d'années puis qu'il est
mort c'est incroyable je détiens un
fragment de l'histoire
et la découverte du bon fragment
pourrait entraîner l'identification
d'une nouvelle espèce de gros potes dans
la baie de Fundy
je crois que j'ai découvert quelque
chose mais j'en suis pas sûr regardez
on dirait un minuscule fragment d'os
c'est peut-être un bout de temps
il y a 200 millions d'années la
nourriture était rare une extinction de
masse avait détruit une bonne partie de
la végétation et pour survivre les
premiers dinosaures devaient pouvoir
digérer même les plantes les plus
coriaces
[Musique]
ils arrachaient des fougères ou des
branches de conifères il ne les mâchait
pas comme le font les vaches mais ils
avaient des gastrolites des pierres dans
leur gésiers qui leur permettaient de
moudre les matières végétales comme les
oiseaux modernes la découverte d'une
dent indique que le chercheur se
rapproche du trésor qu'il espère exhumer
le crâne ne creuse
on établit vraiment des priorités et
cette fois on espère ramener un crâne
cette fois l'équipe des préséropodes
c'est exactement ce qu'elle cherche mais
les premiers faciles de la baie de Fundy
ont été trouvés par hasard au 19e siècle
des géologues ont exploré les falaises
de joggings pour y trouver du charbon
ils lisions plutôt trouver des arbres
fossilisés âgés de 315 millions d'années
est-ce qu'ils ont découvert à
l'intérieur à changer le monde
scientifique à jamais
au milieu du 19e siècle ce site a été
visité par Sears Layal et son compère
sur William Dawson un natif de la
Nouvelle-Écosse c'est ici qu'ils ont
fait une des plus importantes
découvertes aléontologique de tous les
temps en fait cet endroit marque le
début de l'histoire des dinosaures
voici l'endroit où l'ayal les Doors
exactement de cette façon un arbre
c'était effondré et il examinait quant à
l'intérieur ils ont découvert des
ossements qui repoussaient la
chronologie des tétrapodes les reptiles
et les amphibiens plus loin dans
l'échelle des temps géologiques qu'on
avait établi auparavant
les eaux étaient ceux d'une petite
créature de type reptilien qui a vécu il
y a 300 millions d'années 70 millions
d'années avant les premiers dinosaures
et 234 millions d'années avant le
tyrannosaure
Charles Darwin a utilisé cette
découverte pour prouver sa théorie de
l'évolution aujourd'hui encore ce sont
les premiers signes de vie terrestre
jamais retrouvé
[Musique]
le côté le plus intéressant de cette
découverte c'est que les reptiles de
joggans sont les ancêtres des dinosaures
et de tous les reptiles encore vivant
aujourd'hui
longtemps avant l'arrivée des mammifères
des oiseaux ou des dinosaures les
premières créatures à quatre pattes les
tétrapodes ont fait leur premier pas sur
la terre ferme
leurs empreintes fossilisées nous
donnent des informations précieuses sur
la vie des vertébrés terrestres
mais parce qu'il se déplaçait souvent en
eau peu profondes elles sont difficiles
à trouver
seul un expert comme Tyler chat c'est à
quel moment et à quel endroit il faut
les chercher
on sort la nuit parce que l'angle de la
lumière joue un rôle dans le dépistage
des empreintes on ne peut pas contrôler
l'angle du rayonnement solaire mais on
peut contrôler celui de non lanterne
ce rocher a absorbé beaucoup d'eau car
on voit les marques laissées par les
vagues et en mettant la lanterne en
contre-plongée on commence à en voir les
traces aujourd'hui il ne reste que du
rock mais il y a des millions d'années
bien avant l'air des dinosaures un bord
de mer sablonneux s'est allé ici au fil
du temps le mouvement des plaques
tectoniques à surélever le rock
dissimulant bien le fait que cette plage
préhistorique était loin d'être déserte
l'animal qu'on voit se déplaçait en eau
peu profonde il se poussait vers l'avant
et tirait son corps derrière lui
il y a un écart de 70 à 80 cm entre une
empreinte et la suivante donc au minimum
l'animal avait la taille d'un berger
allemand ça signifie que cet animal est
l'ancêtre de toute la vie terrestre de
tous les animaux qui fouillent ou
enfoulé le sol l'évolution de cet animal
a dû produire les premiers amphibiens à
leur tour ces amphibiens ont évolué et
donner naissance aux reptiles que Dawson
et la yell ont découvert dans les
falaises de jungle et finalement les
premiers dinosaures sont apparus
après avoir cherché les traces de leurs
ancêtres à la lueur des lanternes
l'équipe de Tyler chat espère trouver
les empreintes de quelques-uns des
premiers dinosaures de la terre avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard entre temps
l'équipe des projets repos décède de
découvrir les traces d'une nouvelle
espèce sur un site de fouilles
particulièrement ardue
la structure du site ne pourrait pas
être plus complexe avant qu'elle ne soit
emportée par la marée montante
n'a plus que 4 jours pour trouver les
ossements dont elle a besoin pour
identifier une nouvelle espèce de
dinosaure cette fois on espère ramener
un crâne tandis que dans le bassin
dominance l'équipe des chasseurs
d'empreintes est sur la piste de sa
prochaine grande découverte
il y a une semaine tu as des Island en
Nouvelle-Écosse était submergé mais il y
a 220 millions d'années elle était
peuplée de dinosaures
c'est parfait pour le bateau ici
attendent patiemment le jour où ils
pourront suivre la piste de ses animaux
préhistoriques et ils seront peut-être
bientôt récompensés généralement je me
promène avec une pile d'autres poulets
qui me porte chance c'est de la magie
sympathique mais on n'a pas mangé de
poulet depuis un certain temps alors
on dirait bien que ce n'est pas son
genre de chance
oh là là
rien de rien de loin ça ressemblait
vaguement à une empreinte de pas mais de
près pas du tout
ça y est
voilà la tribus c'est l'empreinte de son
pied avec un deux trois orteils voici
l'empreinte de la main
et une autre empreinte plus grosse on a
nos dinosaures fantastiques quel type de
dinosaure a pu laisser ces traces la
datation des rochers qui emprisonne
l'empreinte nous fournit un indice
important
il date de 220 millions d'années par
conséquent l'animal qui a laissé ses
empreintes devaient être l'un des
premiers dinosaures de la terre
c'est la ligne de rupture de cette
section
on va les rassembler
mon empreinte de dinosaure est là alors
il devait venir ici ouais voilà
au minimum on a les traces d'un de deux
de trois herbivores ici
la forme et la taille des empreintes
suggère qu'elles ont été faites par une
animal appelée attribus un dinosaure du
Trias ayant vécu il y a 220 millions
d'années la trepuce était un quadrupède
et il avait un bassin d'oiseau
c'était un petit animal probablement pas
plus haut que ça
il était assez jeune celui-là était plus
âgé mais ce n'est pas un spécimen de
taille adulte celui-là devait se situer
entre les deux autres c'était sans doute
un spécimen juvénile en plein dans
l'adolescence destructrice c'est mignon
les empreintes sont si bien préservées
que je mettais en presque à le voir
debout devant moi en train de se
demander ce que je fais là
j'ai envie de tendre la main pour le
chatouiller sous le menton
mais il est mort depuis 220 millions
d'années
la trehypus est connue grâce à ses
empreintes fossilisées car aucun de ces
ossements n'a jamais été retrouvé des
chasseurs d'empreintes comme chat nous
ont fourni toute l'information
disponible sur un des premiers
dinosaures de la terre
il n'avait pas de doigts comme les
nôtres leurs doigts étaient plus soudés
et plus rapproché il pouvait marcher à
quatre pattes mais la plupart du temps
il levaient leurs membres antérieurs il
courait sur leurs deux pattes
postérieures
les pieds agiles des premiers dinosaures
raisons aidé à survivre dans un monde
peuplé de prédateurs féroce
mais il y a 201 millions d'années leur
monde s'est retourné contre eux au début
de la période du Trias la région de la
baie de Fundy était à la hauteur de
l'équateur et enclavé dans la Pangée
tandis que le super continent se
fracturait des tremblements de terre
secouaient la région ils ont martelé les
falaises jusqu'à ce qu'elle se fissure
200 millions d'années plus tard ces
fractures et ses crevasses sont encore
buriner à la surface des rochers
présentant de graves défis à l'équipe de
tenfield
la structure du site ne pourrait pas
être plus complexe
j'appelle ces vestiges les dinosaures
sismiques parce que leurs ossements ont
été brisés en morceaux et séparés par
les violons tremblement de terre de
l'époque les eaux étaient enfouis une
première fois puis un deuxième
tremblement de terre se produisait et
causait toutes sortes de dommages ce
site est une grande source de
frustration les plus hautes marées de la
planète arrivent ici les fossiles
trouvées le long de ces rives sont donc
saturés d'eau de mer et extrêmement
fragiles
les ossements enfouis dans le substrat
rocheux sont pratiquement bouillies ils
ont la consistance du fromage en crème
et il faut les manipuler avec
délicatesse les os sont si fragiles
qu'ils doivent les consolider avec de la
colle dans la chronologie des fossiles
quand on préserve un seul ossement on a
l'impression d'avoir gagné le gros lot
mais quand on préserve tout un squelette
c'est comme si on gagnait deux gros lots
consécutifs
fouillez la terre à la recherche de
dinosaures morts il y a 200 millions
d'années est un travail minutieux et
frustrant mais fidda que son équipe
savent que leur découverte en valent la
peine lié à trouver une côte qui est une
bonne en a trouvé une plus petite un os
dermique nommé gastralium mais ces deux
os sont très petits
en cherchant le précieux crâne ils ont
peut-être exhumé un autre trésor
en 15 ans de fouilles sur ce site on a
récupéré des fragments de matériel
articulés provenant d'adultes et de
jeunes adultes mais on reste toujours à
l'affût de vestiges de très jeunes
spécimens ou de fragments 2
à vrai dire chaque année on espère
tomber sur un site de nidification
l'équipe continuera de chercher son
crâne mais elle croit maintenant avoir
une chance de découvrir un site de
nidification c'est une bonne raison de
célébrer comme on le fait dans la baie
de Fundy elles sont prêtes les gars on
va se régaler
et wedge les chiens les palourdes ne
font pas bon ménage j'en ai fait
l'expérience santé
c'est bon
on ne pourrait pas faire ça en Alberta
la partie de palourde est terminée et
l'équipe reprend les fouilles avec une
nouvelle ardeur les membres de l'équipe
cherchent une nouvelle espèce de
prosopropodes peut-être qu'ils
trouveront sa pouponnière
trouver un site de nidification ce
serait fantastique
entre temps
de découvrir les traces des plus anciens
dinosaures de la planète à moins qu'elle
ne finissent au fond de l'océan c'est
vraiment dommage de ne pas pouvoir
rapporter ça dans mes bagages
[Musique]
à l'équipe des projets sur le point de
faire une percée mais il est presque à
court de temps
chaque année on espère tomber sur un
site de nidification
tandis que dans la baie de Fundy
l'équipe de chasseurs d'empreinte tente
de transporter les traces de ces
dinosaures de 220 millions d'années loin
de pas des Island avant que la marée
montante ne les redonne à l'océan
ces empreintes sont gravées sur de
lourds blocs de rochers qui ont été
brisés par la force des vagues
j'essaie de trouver une façon de réduire
le poids
le pilote panique reste si je tentais
d'embarquer ces gros blocs de recherche
à bord du bateau
c'est vraiment dommage de ne pas pouvoir
rapporter ça dans mes bagages
aucun noces d'attribus n'a jamais été
retrouvé des empreintes comme celle de
chat sont donc notre seul moyen
d'étudier le comportement d'un des
premiers dinosaures de la planète on va
retourner les blocs en espérant que ça
protégera les empreintes ensuite
j'essaierai de convaincre quelqu'un de
revenir les charger dans un bateau vide
pour les ramener à terre mais si
l'attente est trop longue le
puy-en-courant sous-marin pourrait
redonner à la mer ses blocs et leur
précieuses empreintes où les fracassés
sur le plancher océanique
car le chat profite de chaque seconde
pour en apprendre davantage sur
l'insaisissable attribus
il faut multiplier la longueur de
l'empreinte c'est-à-dire l'écart entre
le bout de leur taille et l'arrière du
talon par 4 regardez
deux trois quatre
ça s'était à peu près à cet auteur ça
c'est les quarts entre la hanche et les
pôles ensuite il faut doubler en
ajoutant une longueur équivalente pour
la queue à peu près jusqu'ici puis la
longueur de la tête et voilà la longueur
approximative de l'animal avec le peu
d'informations tirées d'une série de
trois empreintes mais on séquence c'est
indispensable on peut remplir les vides
et déduire l'apparence de l'animal et il
prend vie il respire
les empreintes fossilisées sont les
témoins muets des dinosaures en
mouvement et elles nous ont laissé une
poignante image de leur comportement on
a découvert des empreintes de dinosaures
partout dans le monde généralement près
des ruisseaux et des rivières la région
de tomberidge en Colombie-Britannique
est un excellent terrain de chasse pour
le paléontologue
un squelette c'est un tas de ce manque
on peut en tirer beaucoup d'informations
mais les empreintes ont été faites par
des animaux vivants comme on n'a pas de
machine à remonter le temps c'est notre
meilleur façon d'observer dinosaures
collabore avec sa femme la paléontologue
Lisa Buckley il y a quelques semaines
ils ont découvert une nouvelle série
d'empreintes de dinosaures mais leur
inspection risque d'être assez
dangereuse
dans un endroit qu'on appelle la gorge
des dinosaures
ici la surface de pistache est
pratiquement verticale
ces pistes ont dû être faites près d'une
pleine littorale il y a 130 ou 140
millions d'années puis la formation des
montagnes a commencé dans cette région
et la plaque tectonique nord-américaine
est entrée en collision avec d'autres
plaques quand une auto s'écrase contre
un mur de brique son capot s'effondre
donc à cause de la formation des
montagnes des pistes horizontales sont
devenus verticales pour atteindre les
pistes mais cree devrait escalader plus
de 18 mètres de paroi rocheuses friable
et il devra faire vite s'il ne veut pas
grimper à la noirceur le canyon ici
étroit qu'il me reste à peine une heure
de bonne lumière
selon l'âge de la paroi rocheuse les
empreintes ont dû s'y fossilisés il y a
140 millions d'années mais il faudra les
examiner de près pour identifier
l'animal qui les a faites on ne sait pas
ce qu'il y a là-haut à peine 40% des
empreintes sont visibles du sol il faut
grimper
ce type de chasse aux dinosaures exige
que les paléontologues et les habiletés
à l'escalade des falaises et qu'il soit
prêt à prendre des risques on se
souvient des dangers d'un site de
fouilles normales mais on les multiplie
par 10 ou même par 100 quand on explore
une surface verticale
tu dois garder les yeux rivés à la corde
et au sang
même une fraction de seconde
d'inattention
pour être fatal à la sécurité de Richard
le risque qu'on va aller à la peine
a découvert une empreinte de bonne
taille parfaitement testée sur le flanc
de la montagne mais quel animal la
laisser là on voit ici l'empreinte d'un
pied à 3 orteils
une première question se pose très vite
l'animal était-il herbivore ou carnivore
chez les carnivores l'empreinte est
généralement un peu plus longue que
large et celle-ci répond à ce critère
un autre indice concerne les doigts des
carnivores ils ont des griffes très
acérées
mais ces Douala semble avoir les
extrémités arrondie
le dernier indice est le plus important
c'est l'empreinte de main qu'on voit
devant celle du pied
c'est définitivement
l'empreinte d'un dinosaure herbivore
il y a 140 millions d'années les
dinosaures herbivores marchaient à
quatre pattes mais les carnivores
étaient des Théropodes des bipède qui
chassaient sur deux pattes
je vais descendre pour observer une très
grande empreinte
voici les contours d'un des doigts
extérieurs à l'extrémité il s'effile et
devient une griffe acérée
en longueur il mesure 62 ou 63 cm mais
il est beaucoup moins large
il s'agit définitivement de l'empreinte
d'un gros carnivore
on a retrouvé que deux ou trois
spécimens d'attente cette période
l'exposition d'une paroi rocheuse qui a
conservé un grand nombre d'empreintes
nous donnera beaucoup d'informations sur
les divertic type d'animaux qui vivaient
dans cette région de la Colombie
Britannique
ont été faites à la fin de la période
jurassique en dehors des faciles de la
Nouvelle-Écosse ce sont les plus
vieilles traces de dinosaures jamais
découvertes au Canada
[Musique]
entre temps dans la baie de Fundy
l'équipe de timfi date a peut-être
trouvé une nouvelle piste qui l'amènera
vers les premiers dinosaures le crâne et
notre meilleure source d'information
mais ces animaux subissent de grands
changements physiques entre la naissance
et l'âge adulte du point de vue de
l'évolution il est essentiel de
comprendre ces changements
ils espèrent encore trouver un crâne
intact mais leur nouvelle liste de
souhaits comprend aussi un nid de
prosaropodes on cherche aussi des
ossements d'animaux beaucoup plus petits
signes possible d'un site de
nidification on pourrait y trouver des
œufs fossilisés ou des squelettes plus
petits
on aimerait trouver un site de
nidification ce serait fantastique
si les chercheurs exument des bébés
dotés des mêmes caractéristiques que les
adultes déjà découverts sur le site ils
auront toutes les preuves nécessaires
pour nommer une nouvelle espèce de
projets
on évite de nommer une nouvelle espèce à
partir de vestiges provenant d'un seul
stade de développement de l'animal qu'il
s'agisse de nouveau-nés ou d'adultes il
est préférable de compléter le tableau
en essayant de relier le squelette d'un
adulte à celui d'un spécimen plus jeune
la découverte d'un site de nidification
dans la baie de Fundy serait une
première en Amérique du Nord mais si
timfi a fait son équipe n'agissent pas
assez vite il sera englouti par la mer
l'équipe des chasseurs d'empreintes elle
doit transporter ses précieux blocs de
rochers hors de l'île avant qu'il ne
coulent
a
identifié d'incroyables pistes de
dinosaures mais si l'océan les engloutit
ils perdra des preuves essentiels à
notre connaissance des premiers
dinosaures à wash and bluff le temps
menace aussi des projets d'un groupe de
paléontologues le temps passe il nous
reste environ un jour et demi
l'équipe de timfi dakh accélère ses
fouilles dans l'espoir d'exhumer un site
de nidification de pros européennes une
découverte encore jamais faite en
Amérique du Nord
en Afrique du Sud il y a de superbes
sites où on a recueilli des nids
complets avec des embryons encore dans
leurs œufs prêts à éclore
en 2005 un site de nidification vieux de
190 millions d'années a été découvert en
Afrique du Sud les autres sites de
nidification exhumés auparavant avaient
100 millions d'années de moins cette
découverte a dévoilé l'existence de
comportement de nidification complexe de
plus l'utilisation répétée de certains
sites par une seule espèce et Lenny très
bien organisée suggèrent que la mère
plaçait peut-être soigneusement ses œufs
après les avoir pour dus
les sites ont aussi révélé des écarts
surprenants dans les stades de
croissance des projets européropodes
certaines parties du squelette se
développent plus vite que des autres le
crâne a une vitesse de croissance plus
lente tandis que celle du coup est
beaucoup plus rapide au cours de sa vie
l'animal semble changer de posture
nouveau-né il marche sur ses quatre
pattes mais à l'âge adulte il marche
généralement sur ses membres postérieurs
en établissant un lien entre nouveau-nés
et un adulte l'équipe des prosopropodes
obtiendrait toute la formation dont elle
a besoin pour ajouter une nouvelle
espèce de pros européropode au
répertoire des dinosaures
on a découvert des ossements tout près
s'il y a d'autres vestiges articulés ici
on devrait les trouver assez rapidement
l'équipe doit travailler plus vite pour
gagner la marée de vitesse tu me file
donc à sortir les outils électriques je
ne suis pas certain des effets du
marteau perforateur sur ses parois
rocheuses on verra bien par bonheur la
chance est de son côté en détachant ses
pierres on a trouvé un autre fragment
d'os
est visible ici et l'autre sur ce
deuxième fragment
il s'emboîtent parfaitement
avant de savoir quel type d'OS il a
découvert le chercheur se retrouve
devant un public un groupe d'amateurs
locaux dirigé par son collègue taille le
chat vous voyez ces petits sacs avec les
languettes oranges
il contiennent les fragments d'os qu'ils
ont exhumés dans mon carnet j'ai des
images de créatures du même type
mais ça m'étonnerait qu'ils aient trouvé
le même animal
la vedette du site de fouille comment ça
va
c'est un bout de côte
il est enfoncé dans ce rock depuis 200
millions d'années
grâce au travail de teenfield des
chasseurs de dinosaures locaux cette
région de la Nouvelle-Écosse est devenue
la Mecque des amateurs de dinosaures qui
affluent vers la petite ville de
pearlboro pour visiter son musée mais à
quelques rues de là on peut trouver un
autre type de musée géré par le
paléontologue amateur Eldon George
c'est un seul office c'est mon animal de
compagnie
est une légende locale et une vedette
dans la communauté géologique il rétise
les plages à la recherche de fossiles et
de minéraux depuis l'âge de 8 ans
j'ai trouvé ces empreintes le 31 mars
ce jour-là la découverte d'Alden George
est entré dans l'histoire
j'ai trouvé ça dans cet ou 8 cm d'eau
au début je croyais que c'était des
traces d'oiseaux
puis je me suis rendu compte que j'avais
trouvé quelque chose de très rare
il avait raison ces empreintes
minuscules ont été faites par un bébé
c'est l'office il y a 25 millions
d'années elles font partie des plus
petites traces de dinosaures jamais
découvertes
il y a plus de 200 millions d'années ce
bébé c'est le physique partagé son
territoire avec la trille puce ils
iraient et se nourrissaient dans un
monde de jungle chaude et fertile mais
ils n'ont pas survécu à la destruction
de leur monde
pourtant les dinosaures que tu aimes
fines étaient en train d'exhumer en
réussi à survivre et à évoluer dans un
terrible univers post-apocalyptique
la mission de feedac prouvé qu'une
nouvelle espèce de projets ici et
survécu au cataclysme en est au spring
final il a besoin de preuves concluantes
comme un crâne ou un site de
nidification et il en est bien prêt on a
une dizaine d'éléments ce qui n'est pas
trop mal mais on doit vraiment s'assurer
qu'aucun vestige articulé ne risque
d'être érodé et c'est dur on a encore il
faudra les recueillir
le temps passe il nous reste environ un
jour et demi
ce vestiges sont peut-être à portée de
main mais pour l'équipe des préseropodes
la marée monte et le temps presse
dans la baie de Fundy l'équipe des
chasseurs d'empreintes combat aussi la
marée pour sauver les traces des plus
anciens dinosaures du Canada
c'est absolument fantastique
dans le bassin de ménage l'équipe des
chasseurs d'empruntent à monter une
mission de sauvetage pour préserver les
traces préhistoriques d'un dinosaure
attribus avant que la marée ne les
emporte tandis gawa Sun bluff l'équipe
des préseropodes dispose de quelques
heures à peine pour recueillir des
informations vitales à l'identification
d'une nouvelle espèce sans quoi son
dépôt d'ossement deviendra un dépôt
sous-marin
l'équipe fait une dernière descente
périlleuse pour récupérer le maximum de
vestiges avant que l'océan ne recouvre
la plage
on entend déjà les vagues de la marée
qui va bientôt engloutir le site
pour protéger des fossiles vieux de 200
millions d'années les paléontologues ont
recours à une technique éprouvée on
utilise le plâtre et la toile de jute
depuis des centaines d'années
les membres de l'équipe des préséropodes
de croix avoir trouvé l'épreuve
nécessaire pour ajouter une nouvelle
espèce à la liste des premiers
dinosaures mais ils ne le sauront
qu'après avoir ramené les vestiges au
laboratoire
une chose est sûre ces minuscules
trésors ont une véritable épopée à
raconter
ces dinosaures ont été témoins d'un des
pires épisodes d'extinction de masse et
ils ont survécu contrairement à la
majorité des organismes de l'époque les
ont connu leur sursis cosmique lorsque
la Pangée s'est fracturée il y a 200
millions d'années
les déserts enclavés se sont transformés
en riches régions côtières les jungles
l'ont repoussé et au fil du temps les
prêtres ont évolué pour devenir des
géants
étaient les ancêtres des futurs ce
repodent les plus gros animaux jamais vu
sur terre
[Musique]
il y a 200 millions d'années ces petits
dinosaures ont connu une incroyable
destinée et ils ont laissé un héritage
extraordinaire aujourd'hui l'équipe de
timfi date tente de préserver leur
vestiges avant qu'il ne soit emporté par
la mer
de l'autre côté de la baie Tyler shy est
revenu en bateau sans son équipe afin de
récupérer les empreintes de la tribus
je vais essayer de manœuvrer jusque là
j'ai du mal à croire que personne n'a vu
ce site depuis 20 ans ou plus les
empreintes de dinosaures sont encore
fraîches elles paraissent de plus en
plus elle valait bien un deuxième voyage
c'est absolument fantastique
la nouvelle saison de chasse aux
empreintes de Tal le chat finit en
beauté
je me sens comme un enfant de 3 ans avec
un nouveau jouet
aujourd'hui quand j'ai repris le bateau
la vue seule valait le voyage mais en
plus j'ai pu récupérer mes empreintes de
dinosaures personne n'a pu avoir une
meilleure journée à moins que l'homme ne
se mette à tomber du ciel moi je suis
aussi heureux qu'un cochon dans la boue
et
vestiges de tenfi dag sont sur le point
d'être ramené au musée
[Musique]
très bien
on a réussi l'équipe fait ses bagages
mais elles sont déjà à la saison
prochaine
l'expérience m'a été très profitable
j'ai même découvert des eaux je ne m'y
attendais pas du tout
au début de cette saison de fouille je
me disais que je ne reviendrai peut-être
pas ici avant longtemps
mais ces dépôts semblent devenir très
intéressant
même si tu me fiduck explore ce site
depuis près de 20 ans chaque année il y
fait de surprenante découverte
tandis que les vestiges préhistoriques
sont chargés avec précautions dans les
véhicules la nature reprend ses droits
allons-y il faut retourner au musée
avant le retour de la marée au revoir
mais leur travail est loin d'être fini
ce n'est qu'au bout de longs mois
d'analyse méticuleuse qu'ils sauront
exactement ce qu'ils ont trouvé
ce sont les plus anciens eaux de
dinosaures du Canada ils sont donc
difficiles à exposer mais après neuf
mois de travail on observe des
caractéristiques dans certains éléments
qui semblent suggérer qu'il s'agit bien
d'une nouvelle espèce
le dévouement de l'équipe de timfida qui
a permis une importante découverte mais
il sait que son travail dans la baie de
Fundy est loin d'être fini
au cours des prochains mois les maris
exposeront d'autres secrets
préhistoriques dans les falaises de
joggings et Tom FIDA qui reviendra pour
creuser le passé à la recherche des
premiers dinosaures de notre planète
dans le prochain épisode de sur la piste
des dinosaures deux équipes tenteront de
résoudre des plus grands mystères de la
terre la véritable cause de l'extinction
des dinosaures
ont-ils été victime d'un astéroïde où
était-il déjà danger lorsqu'il s'est
écrasé sur la planète
[Musique]
c'est la saison des dinosaures
en ce moment les plus grands
paléontologues de la planète fouille le
territoire canadien pour découvrir un
monde disparu depuis des millions
d'années
il combattront la chaleur les
inondations et le temps en cherchant les
traces des dinosaures
et les plus extraordinaires créatures
jamais vu sur terre revivrons bientôt
car nous marchons sur la piste des
dinosaures
il y a 66 millions d'années un astéroïde
s'est écrasé sur la terre et cette
collision cosmique a mis fin a l'air des
dinosaures
mais cette théorie est-elle vraie dans
cet épisode sur la piste des dinosaures
deux équipes creusent le sol à la
recherche d'un disque qui les aideront à
résoudre mystère datant de 66 millions
d'années l'extinction des dinosaures
dans les prairies de la Saskatchewan
l'équipe de Miguel retrace les derniers
pas de titan tandis qu'à Johanna en
Alberta l'équipe du Musée royal cherche
un dinosaure à corne plutôt
insaisissable si les deux équipes
parviennent à découvrir d'autres
vestiges elle connaîtront les secrets de
la vie de ses colosses et de leur mort
à Montréal une équipe d'étudiants en
paléontologie de l'université Miggy va
bientôt partir vers l'ouest
en ce moment il prépare une expédition
de trois semaines en Saskatchewan il y a
des trucs morts là-dedans oui il
travailleront sous la direction du
paléontologue ans
je crois que tout le monde les adore et
si on expose plus de vestiges ce sera
une très bonne chose pour le musée
a chassé les dinosaures partout du
Nunavut jusqu'en Afrique son champ
d'intérêt et leur évolution il a retracé
leur vie jusqu'à l'extinction et plus
loin encore
en étudiant la fin de ses Titans il a
obtenu une perspective saisissante de
notre monde il y a 66 millions d'années
l'extinction de masse des dinosaures est
un sujet très controversé on sait que
tous les dinosaures non naviaires se
sont éteints à cette époque mais des
questions importantes demeur sans
réponse comment sont-ils morts est-ce
que l'extinction de masse a été rapide
ou lente quelles espèces ont disparues
en premier et qu'elles ont été les
étapes de l'extinction
ces réponses sont enfouies dans un site
des Prairies canadiennes à 3500 km de
Montréal bienvenue en saskatchevan
l'équipe fait route vers un site de
fouille du parc national des prairies
dans les bases de la Saskatchewan
on se rend la base surtout parce qu'on y
a trouvé de superbes blocs de rochers
qui datent de la fin du Crétacé l'époque
de l'extinction de masse
ceci de contient les ossements de
certains des derniers dinosaures de
notre planète
on sera aussi tout on a découvert une
partie du squelette d'un dinosaure avec
de canard qu'on a surnommé
blademontosaure il était énorme
[Musique]
était un herbivore gigantesque qui a
disparu il y a 66 millions d'années
un des derniers dinosaures de la planète
est sur ce site
grâce à lui on pourra peut-être répondre
à des questions comme celle-là est-ce
que les dinosaures évoluaient encore
juste avant l'extinction massive ce
serait phénoménal
l'équipe est composée en grande partie
de nos vies et de jeunes citadins qui
ignorent ceux qui les attend mais ils
peuvent déjà oublier le camp d'été
j'emmène des étudiants qui ne sont
jamais allés dans l'Ouest canadien
souvent ils n'ont même jamais dormi sous
une tente après avoir établi le camp
l'équipe va se mettre au travail son
objectif est de trouver la réponse à
l'une des questions les plus
controversées de tous les temps pour
quelle raison les dinosaures se sont-ils
éteints
les premiers dinosaures ont évolué sur
terre il y a 230 millions d'années et
ils ont régné en maître jusqu’à leur
extinction qu'il y a 66 millions
d'années
ils ont disparu exactement à l'époque où
un astéroïde s'est écrasé sur la
péninsule du Yucatan
avec autant de force que 10 milliards
d'armes nucléaires
mais l'astéroïde a-t-il vraiment anéanti
les dinosaures ou leur nombre avait-il
commencé à baisser bien avant
à 600 km à l'ouest une autre équipe de
chasseurs de fossiles se pose la même
question
il y a 70 millions d'années sur le
territoire actuel de Drum Heller en
Alberta les dinosaures étaient peut-être
déjà affectés par les changements
environnementaux longtemps avant la
chute de l'astéroïde
les traces de leur dernier pas sont
peut-être incrustés dans ces rochers et
c'est ce que le paléontologue François
terrien espère trouver
on trouve des fossiles dans le sud de
l'Alberta depuis des milliers d'années
les membres des Premières nations les
connaissaient depuis très longtemps mais
il ne savait pas quels animaux les
avaient laissés
les expéditions de François terrien
l'ont conduit vers de nombreux sites en
Europe et en Amérique du Nord pour y
étudier la forme des eaux et les
habitats des dinosaures il y a recueilli
des indices qui lui ont permis de se
créer une image de leur monde disparu il
croit que certains des meilleurs indices
sont ici dans les rochers qui bordent la
rivière reddeeer c'est de quoi je me
pose une question en particulier est-ce
que des changements climatiques et
environnementaux ont joué un rôle dans
l'extinction des dinosaures ou bien
l'impact du météorite qui s'est écrasé
sur la terre il y a 66 millions d'années
a-t-il été l'unique responsable de leur
mort
le paléontologue canadien travaille pour
le musée royal situé à drame en Alberta
on y trouve la plus grande collection
d'ossements de tout le Canada le musée
rempli de fossiles datant des derniers
jours des dinosaures cet été François
terrien voudrait y ramener un trésor
unique le squelette de narinoceratops
selon son hypothèse ce dinosaure vivait
il y a 70 millions d'années au moment
des premiers changements climatiques
les graines sont les seules preuves
fossiles de son existence et on en a
trouvé qu'à drum healer cette découverte
est excitante parce que la rhinoceratops
est probablement le dinosaure accorde le
plus rare qu'on ait jamais découvert en
Alberta mais on a retrouvé que deux
crânes absolument rien d'autre il n'y a
aucun vestige du reste de son corps
le squelette complet aiderait le
paléontologue à comprendre comment le
dinosaure s'adapter à un monde instable
et s'il était vulnérable au changement
environnementaux même avant l'impact du
météorite
[Musique]
pour en avoir le cœur net François
terrien a demandé l'aide de l'équipe du
Musée
parfois en marchant vers le site on
aperçoit un aigle à tête blanche
au-dessus de nos têtes on ne verrait
jamais ça dans un bureau
ce n'est pas un emploi parce qu'on se
dit ouais aujourd'hui je pratique mon
passe-temps favori
l'équipe du Musée a commencé à explorer
ce site l'an dernier quand un habitant
de la région il a trouvé des ossements
par hasard
il faut gratter très doucement
pour ne rien abîmer
depuis 10 ans Dana McLoud cherche des
faciles à drum eller avant de
reconstituer les spécimens pour les
exposer au musée
aujourd'hui son regard expérimenté à
découvert un os de mâchoire datant de 70
millions d'années
et on dirait bien qu'il provient du
dinosaure qu'ils sont dus rechercher
ici j'ai un aspect dentaire de cératopia
on croit que c'est celui de
narinoceratops et voilà ça mâchoire
arrière l'équipe cherche un trésor et
elle espère bien le trouver dans le mec
là vient de découvrir un premier bijou
un squelette complet darhinoceratops
leur permettrait de mieux comprendre le
monde des dinosaures et les changements
climatiques qu'ils ont dû affronter
[Musique]
en Saskatchewan l'équipe de meguil est
en route vers le site où l'an dernier
elle a découvert un admentozor
comme aucune route ne mène au site de
fouilles sa journée travaille commence
par une randonnée de 6 km
on se dirige vers un affleurement de la
formation de French man qui protège la
limite de la fin du Crétacé
cette limite marque l'extraction de tous
les dinosaures et d'environ 75% de la
vie qui existait sur la planète telle
qu'on la connaissait alors
malgré les 40 degrés étouffants la
marche en vaut la peine car la preuve de
l'extinction de masse est sous leurs
pieds on y va fantastique
tu as vu ça
un simple coup de pioche révèle la
démarcation entre le présent et le passé
préhistorique dans le domaine on
l'appelle la limite KT aux limites
crétacées tertiaire elle marque la fin
du Crétacé et le début de l'air
tertiaire selon la datation cette ligne
remonte à 66 millions d'années le plus
fabuleux c'est la simplicité de la chose
tout ce qui est en dessous de la ligne
contient des dinosaures et tout ce qui
est au-dessus n'en contient aucun elle
marque l'extinction de tous les
dinosaures de la planète
cette limite indique le moment où un
astéroïde d'une largeur de 10 km c'était
écrasé sur le territoire du Mexique
actuel déclenchant une tempête infernale
de feu et de glace
des milliards d'automne de débris ont
été projetés vers le ciel
bloquant la lumière du soleil et
provoquant un hiver perpétuel certains
débris sont tombés ici et ans Larsson a
trouvé une méthode d'identification
assez simple
c'est de l'argile pur c'est bien la
limite
on dirait de la pâte dentifrice le sol
est plein de quartz choquées et
d'iridium provenant des retombées
ces rochers renferment certains des
derniers dinosaures ayant foulé la
planète il y a 66 millions d'années
mais l'équipe doit encore les trouver
[Musique]
un cataclysme isolé a-t-il anéanti les
puissants dinosaures ou les changements
climatiques ont-ils été les vrais
responsables de leur destruction deux
équipes cherchent des indices pour
résoudre le même mystère quel événement
a provoqué la mort des dinosaures en
Alberta l'équipe du Musée royal chasser
le trésor unique au monde un squelette
complète d'arrinoceratops c'est un
nouveau spécimen il est nouveau ah ouais
tandis quand ça se catch on l'équipe de
Meggy exhume colosse de 5 tonnes qui
expliquera peut-être la fin des
dinosaures
l'objectif des prochains jours sera de
suivre la piste du squelette
dans l'Ouest canadien deux équipes
cherchent à éclaircir un mystère qui
dure depuis très longtemps quel
événement a provoqué la mort des
dinosaures
en Alberta l'équipe du Musée Royal veut
trouver les premiers ossements d'un
corps d'un rhinoceratops et dans le parc
national des prairies en Saskatchewan
l'équipe de Miguel creuse pour connaître
la vérité sur la fin des dinosaures
la réponse est si proche qu'ils peuvent
même la goûter
ça c'est le goût de la mort
certains de ces animaux ont
manifestement disparu mais d'autres
existent encore aujourd'hui ces vestiges
sont ceux d'une tortue on trouve les
mêmes tortues dans nos rivières et nos
lacs
si certains animaux ont pu survivre à
l'impact du météorite pourquoi les
dinosaures n'ont-ils pas résister
Hans Larsson croit qu'un gigantesque
carbivore surnommé ladmintosaure détient
la clé du mystère
est le seul air bivor géant répertoriés
dans la chronologie du rock de cette
période
si on trouve un nombre suffisant de
vestiges on pourra comparer cette Edmond
toser à ceux qui proviennent d'une
période antérieure
les différences observées pourraient
leur fournir des indices sur l'état de
l'écosystème peu avant l'extinction de
masse
on cherche à connaître le modèle
d'extinction en quelque sorte si on peut
établir ce modèle on comprendra mieux le
processus est-ce que l'impact a été ce
processus l'arme qui a anéanti notre
planète
l'an dernier Hans Larsson a exhumé une
partie des eaux de ce dinosaure de
Sainton mais cette année il veut tout
récupérer
ce dépôt
contient deux vertèbres du bas du dos
les vertèbres d'un grand dinosaure avec
de canard
[Musique]
on a creusé ici l'an dernier pour
explorer un peu en commençant et on a
découvert une série de côtes on a dû les
rayons fouir parce qu'on n'avait pas de
permis de collecte à ce moment-là cette
année on a le permis alors on va creuser
de nouveau et recueillir le maximum de
ce manque
l'objectif des prochains jours sera de
suivre la piste du squelette
c'est parti
la chasse à montosor est ouverte mais ce
ne sera pas le premier spécimen
découvert dans les Badlands de la
Saskatchewan
[Musique]
vers 1870 le gouvernement d'Ottawa a
envoyé ici une équipe d'arpenteurs pour
dresser la carte d'une nouvelle
frontière entre le Canada et les
États-Unis un membre de l'équipe allait
devenir le premier chasseur de dinosaure
Canadien
a participé à l'étude géologique dont le
but était de dresser la carte du 49e
parallèle du lac Supérieur jusqu'au
montagne rushes c'était le fils du
recteur de l'université mégil William
Dawson
une maladie infantile avait courbée sa
colonne vertébrale mais sa vitalité sa
curiosité était restée intacte
en 1874 il est passé par ici avec son
cheval et son chariot et il a recueilli
les premiers fossiles de dinosaures du
Canada
les tous premiers et les a expédiés à
son père
où on a identifié les vestiges d'un
dinosaure à bec de canard 150 ans plus
tard mais Gilles est de retour ici c'est
très satisfaisant de revenir à notre
point de départ en quelque sorte
les étudiants viennent de découvrir une
côte tirée de la même espèce gigantesque
de canard de l'Amérique du Nord
c'était un géant avec un crâne 2 m et
demi de long
l'énorme tête de cette herbivore se
prolongeait en un bec arrondi et
dépourvu dedans c'est ce qui explique
son surnom de dinosaure à bec de canard
[Musique]
je creuse sous cette vertèbre pour qu'on
puisse aménager une tranchée autour
d'elle
découvrir une autre preuve de la taille
gigantesque de edmontosaure
chacune de ces vertèbres faisait un demi
mètre
la mentosaure mesurait 10 mètres de long
comme les wagons de train
et son poids de 100 tonnes surpassait
celui d'un éléphant moderne c'était un
des plus gros herbivores de son époque
ur adulte devait consommer
quotidiennement au moins 100 kg de
végétation
grâce aux dents remplaçables plantés à
l'arrière de sa gueule il pouvait même
inclure le bois dans son régime riche en
fibres
en fait ces vaches du Crétacé pouvait
mâcher à peu près n'importe quoi ce qui
leur donnait un sérieux avantage lorsque
la nourriture se faisait rare
[Musique]
jusqu'à ce que ces herbivores deviennent
eux-mêmes une source d'aliments pour les
carnivores le dinosaure à bec de canard
devait vivre dans la peur parce que le
seul gros carnivore de la région était
le tyrannosaure
spécimen a été retrouvé non loin de là
il s'appelle Scotti et c'est le
tyrannosaure le plus lourd qu'on n'est
jamais découvert
il est aussi long que l'admintosor mais
son corps est plus large
[Musique]
malgré sa taille démesurée le mentor
était étonnamment rapide et sous le
couvert d'une forêt danse il avait de
bonnes choses d'échapper à son
poursuivant plus gros et plus pesant
[Musique]
le tyrannosaure et l'ED mentosaure
faisait partie des derniers dinosaures
de la terre
et ses étudiants espèrent que les
nouveaux ossements les aideront à
comprendre pourquoi ces géants en péril
tandis que d'autres espèces comme les
crocodiles et les tortues ont réussi à
survivre
[Musique]
adrom heart en Alberta François terrien
et son équipe continuent leur fuir dans
l'espoir de découvrir un dinosaure à
cornes très rare
c'est un nouveau spécimen ou celui qui
était déjà là il est nouveau ah ouais
l'équipe cherche un squelette
d'arinoceratops à peine deux crânes de
cette espèce ont été exhumées en
Amérique du Nord et on sait très peu de
choses sur son corps
un squelette complet dévoilerait la
taille de l'animal
mais il permettrait aussi de comprendre
son rôle dans le monde où il vivait et
où il est mort
[Musique]
il y a 70 millions d'années une vaste
mer intérieure serpentait à travers
l'Amérique du Nord cette mère avait
généré un écosystème chaud et humide
mais 4 millions d'années avant la chute
du météorite les conditions climatiques
se sont mises à changer
regardez cette affleurement rocheux
là-bas on voit qu'il est composé de
différentes couches de rochers
chacune de ces couches montre les divers
changements de l'environnement
c'est une couche de charbon elle marque
un ancien environnement marécage
juste en dessous de la ligne noire on
voit un niveau géologique blanc assez
épais c'est la preuve qu'une rivière
coulait là à l'époque
ses couches de rocher démontrent que les
dinosaures ont dû affronter des
changements climatiques comme nous
leur mère intérieure s'est rétrécie leur
jungle sont mortes remplacées par des
forêts plus fraîches et moins humides on
sait déjà que la rhinoceratops a survécu
dans ce nouvel environnement mais a-t-il
été forcé de s'y adapter voilà c'est
nettoyé pour le savoir l'équipe devrait
trouver des eaux de son squelette
mais à 10 mètres à peine du site de
fouilles principales Marc Mitchell vient
de faire une remarquable découverte
en ce moment vous regardez l'omoplate ou
scapulum d'un dinosaure à corne
et là on voit la hanche où il y a de
dinosaure à cornes
ce sont les ossements d'un animal plus
âgé peut-être un adulte
c'est une découverte importante car ce
sont les premiers ossements du corps de
narinoseratops jamais exhumé
après une longue attente une image
complète de cette insaisissable créature
se formera bientôt
la chasse aux dinosaures à corne se
poursuit et l'équipe du Musée royal
espère faire une découverte historique
les premiers dinosaures à plumes de
l'hémisphère Ouest ce n'est pas
fantastique ça et pendant que l'équipe
de miggie cherche à savoir la vérité sur
la fin des dinosaures elle va exhumer
une surprise qu'à des ailes
dans l'Ouest canadien deux équipes
enquêtes sur la fin des dinosaures en
Alberta l'équipe du Musée Royal a trouvé
la clé de mystère anciens mais il lui
faudra plus d'informations
[Musique]
en réalité on cherche simplement toutes
les pièces du casse-tête
on a toutes ces couches de rochers on y
trouve la limite KT qui marque
l'extinction de masse on a tous ces
fossiles c'est le gardien des 300 000 à
500 000 dernières années de la vie des
dinosaures
les chercheurs savent que certains
animaux comme les tortues et les lézards
ont survécu à l'astéroïde meurtrier mais
pourquoi les dinosaures n'y sont pas
arrivés Hans Larsson devra découvrir
d'autres fossiles pour répondre à cette
question oui on a découvert le squelette
partiel d'un edmondosaure sous un site
incroyablement riche il contient
plusieurs centaines de fossiles qu'on va
utiliser afin d'évaluer la Paléo
biodiversité de la région juste avant
l'extinction massive des dinosaures
aujourd'hui les étudiants ont trouvé le
fossile d'un dinosaure qui imitait les
autres ruches
les ornithumidités avaient de nombreux
traits en commun avec les oiseaux les os
de leurs membres les plus développés
étaient creux et leur pâte pendaient
directement sous leur corps même leur
crâne se ressemblaient et leur
nidomimidité était le plus rapide des
dinosaures à deux pattes les
ornithomymides étaient des dinosaures
imitateurs d'autruche ils étaient
incroyablement rapides mais leur
mâchoire n'avait pas dedans il se
nourrissait sans doute de végétation et
ils étaient peut-être omnivores
a découvert un dinosaure semblable à un
oiseau dans les Badlands de la
Saskatchewan mais ce n'est pas le
premier ornithumidité exhumé au Canada
en 2008 terriens a fait une découverte
historique
elle a transformé sa vie et
révolutionner les connaissances
accumulées jusque là sur la famille des
ornithominidés voilà l'endroit
au début on savait seulement qu'on avait
trouvé une partie du squelette d'un
dinosaure imitateur d'autres ruche mais
on gratte le rock j'ai eu de la chance
sur une pièce j'ai trouvé la striation
noire qui signale la présence de plumes
on a eu bien du mal à y croire
[Musique]
c'était la première fois qu'on
découvrait des preuves de la présence de
dinosaures à plumes en Amérique du Nord
on peut maintenant soutenir l’hypothèse
que les ailes ont évolué non pas à
partir d'animaux volants mais d'animaux
terrestres
son corps était couvert de duvet soyeux
fin comme des cheveux et ses ailes de
grandes plumes en Pénée comme celle des
oiseaux modernes incapables de voler on
a donc formulé une autre hypothèse sur
l'origine des ailes pourquoi ont-elles
fini par évoluer si ce n'était pas pour
le vol c'était probablement pour le
signal visuel et la parade nuptiale
les plus difficiles à préparer de toute
ma carrière mais le résultat a été
phénoménal les premiers dinosaures à
plume de l'hémisphère Ouest
ce n'est pas fantastique ça
j'ai fait ma victoire en faisant tatouer
l'image de ces dinosaures sur ma jambe
ça ce sont des ornithes à plumes j'ai
appelé le mâle parce que c'est là qu'on
l'a trouvé le bébé je l'ai surnommé
Twitter
et ses étudiants sont en train d'exhumer
l'ornithominidés qui vivait il y a 66
millions
en continuant leur fouille ils ont
découvert son petit cousin à plumes
d'un oiseau
il a un extérieur très très dense avec
un trou au centre ça nous indique
clairement qu'il s'agit d'un os
d'oiseaux il ressemble aux os des
oiseaux qu'on voit marcher sur le sol
encore aujourd'hui
à présent les scientifiques croient que
tous les oiseaux sont des descendants
des dinosaures
même si les dinosaures ont disparu il y
a 66 millions d'années ils ont laissé un
héritage génétique qu'on peut encore
admirer en plein vol
mais les deux équipes manquent encore de
réponse
l'équipe de Médine n'a que trois jours
pour déduire quelle dinosaures ont
survécu à l'apocalypse et pour quelle
raison
en Alberta l'équipe du Musée Royal a
découvert le squelette de narinoseratops
à présent elle doit retrouver ses amis
et ses ennemis c'était un champ de
massacre ils sont venus et ils ont pris
tout ce qu'il pouvait
dans les Badlands de la Saska l'équipe
de Miguel a exhumé des fossiles de
montrant que certains animaux ont
survécu à l'astéroïde meurtrier mais
elle ne sait pas pourquoi les dinosaures
ont péri en Alberta l'équipe du Musée a
découvert des ossements confirmants que
son dinosaure à corn a vécu durant une
période de bouleversement climatique
mais il lui en faudra davantage pour
reconstituer un monde prêt apocalyptique
et là
il y a 70 millions d'années des
changements climatiques ont transformé
le territoire de l'Alberta actuel les
jungle chaude et humides se sont
asséchés et ont céder la place à des
forêt moins denses et plus fraîches
mais la rhinoceratops s'est adapté au
changement de son habitat il a pu
tolérer le climat plus sec de son nouvel
environnement
ce dinosaure va jouer un rôle important
dans notre compréhension de l'évolution
des animaux de cette période il nous
montrera comment ils ont réagi au
changement climatique et
environnementaux
mais d'autres espèces de dinosaures
auraient-elles pu survivre l'équipe
trouve d'abord un minuscule indice ça
c'est une petite dent de tropodent
d'un petit vélociraptor il était à peu
près haut comme ça
avec des dents comme celle-là
il avait certainement avantage à être
carnivore
il est trop odons étaient de petits
prédateurs leur plume ont pu leur servir
d'isolants et les garder au chaud même
si leur monde refroidissait mais comment
ont-ils pu se nourrir manifestement
c'était un champ de massacre jeancher de
différents quartiers d'animaux morts
ils sont venus ils ont pris tout ce
qu'il pouvait des opportunistes
à la fois chasseur Richard Rognard les
Troodons étaient peut-être capables de
dévorer les carcasses d'animaux plus
gros mais qui n'avait pas su s'adapter
et comme il n'était pas très gros il ne
mangeait pas beaucoup
cela signifie-t-il que seuls les petits
dinosaures ont survécu au climat plus
froid et que les grands dinosaures se
sont éteints avant la chute du météore
en continuant son travail l'équipe
découvre que des prédateurs de grande
taille ont chassis ici comme les autres
c'est une dent de dinosaure probablement
celle d'un albertosaure un théropode un
peu plus petit que le tyrannosaure mais
quand même assez gros
ce n'est pas le premier vestige du grand
carnivore le premier spécimen
d'albertozor a été exhumé près de Drum
Herrer il y a plus d'un siècle
il a été découvert en 1884 par Joseph
terroll un géologue au service du
gouvernement canadien
aujourd'hui le plus grand musée de
dinosaure du Canada porte son nom
descendez la rivière en radeau à la
recherche de
ce charbon en fait et en cours de route
il a découvert une chose très différente
le premier crâne fossilisé de
l'albertosaure au début personne ne
savait quoi penser de ces faciles à
l'aspect féroce
à peu près 20 ans plus tard en 1905 le
premier paléontologue qui s'est appelé à
la description du tyrannosaure a compris
que le spécimen de Joseph torrell était
un proche parent de ce dinosaure il a
même appelé Albertosaurus en l'honneur
de l'Alberta qui était devenu une
province canadienne cette année là
mais pourquoi l'albertozor était-il si
proche de narinoceratops il y a 70
millions d'années
l'albertosaure mangeait probablement les
restes du seratopien il a dû laisser des
dents dans la carcasse
l'alberto geor laissait souvent des
dents Brant lentes dans ses proies
ensuite ces dents repoussaient comme ça
d'un requin
cette dent suggère une hypothèse
intéressante
ces grands prédateurs avaient besoin
d'une nourriture abondante
ces forêts plus sages devaient donc
abriter plusieurs types de dinosaures et
pas seulement des espèces plus petites
si l'équipe trouve des faciles provenant
de divers groupes de dinosaures dans ces
collines elle saura exactement quelles
espèces s'adapter à un monde en pleine
évolution et quelles espèces étaient
déjà vouées à l'extinction
nos dinosaures albertin ont vécu il y a
70 millions d'années mais ceux qu'on a
découvert en Saskatchewan vivait encore
4 millions d'années plus tard juste
avant la chute de l'astéroïde de
meurtrier l'équipe de Meggy la exhumé un
edmontosaure de 5 tonnes juste sous la
limite KT qui marque la période
d'extinction de masse on peut donc
affirmer que cette espèce de dinosaure
avait survécu du moins jusqu'à ce moment
là chaque fois qu'on trouve un dinosaure
plus près de la limite on obtient
davantage d'informations chaque spécimen
a donc une grande importance
durant cette période trois grands types
de dinosaures dominaient le paysage les
familles de dinosaures qui ont vécu peu
de temps avant l'extinction de masse
était différente de celle qui évoluaient
la 10 millions d'années plus tôt
la journée il n'y avait plus qu'une
espèce de grande dinosaure avec de
canard une espèce de dinosaure à corne
géant et une espèce de carnivore géante
si on considère le nombre des espèces on
voit que certains groupes de dinosaures
étaient passés de plusieurs à une seule
espèce
c'est un changement très important
les changements climatiques étaient-ils
à blâmer
il y a 70 millions d'années la vaste mer
intérieure qui traverse cette région a
commencé à s'assécher
beaucoup d'espèces de dinosaures ont
disparu avec elle mais toutes les
créatures n'ont pas souffert dans ce
nouvel environnement
le plus intéressant
c'était en baisse
les autres animaux vertébrés
c'est-à-dire tous ceux qui sont dotés
d'une épine dorsale et dedans ne semble
pas avoir eu le même problème
en fait leur diversité aurait même
augmenté à cette époque plus on
s'approche de la ligne d'extinction plus
l'assemblage des lézards amphibiens et
crocodile paraît variés
les animaux n'étaient pas les seuls à
évoluer
les plantes se diversifiaient aussi
[Musique]
on a trouvé des fossiles de végétaux
oh mon Dieu
voilà le lynx
cette découverte est aussi excitante que
celle d'un dinosaure et j'adore les
dinosaures mais ça c'est une feuille de
plante complète qui provient d'une
angiosme les sauts appartiennent aux
gens Salix il n'était pas aussi grand
que les saules pleureurs modernes et il
ressemblait à nos sols en plus petit si
on trouve 200 autres fossiles comme
celui-là on pourra en déduire la
température
précipitations et le cycle saisonnier de
la région
l'équipe de Meggy il trouve d'autres
feuilles fossilisées
elle prouve que peu de temps avant
l'extinction des dinosaures les espèces
de plantes devenaient plus variées elle
s'adaptait aux nouvelles environnement
et elles y proliférer
les forêts se peuplés de chaîne et le
sol et des plantes à fleurs couvraient
leur sol
en attendant sa croire que les
dinosaures vivaient dans une espèce de
vie d'écologie parce qu'on entend
rarement parler des animaux et végétaux
fantastiques qui partageaient ces
territoires
on cherche à reconstituer une communauté
complète à partir des fossiles d'animaux
et de plantes qu'on retrouve ils sont
tous reliés
les dinosaures avaient survécu à 5
millions d'années de changements
climatiques réduit en nombre jamais
vaincu
mais un autre changement se profilait à
l'horizon
un grand remaniement si puissant et si
dévastateur qu'il transformerait la
surface de la Terre pendant des millions
d'années
l'expédition devra bientôt plier bagages
mais son équipe sont sur le point de
découvrir comment les dinosaures ont
péri
tandis qu'en Alberta l'équipe du Musée
royal tiral doit compléter le portrait
robot de l'insaisissable à rhinoceratops
cherche à résoudre un mystère la chute
soudaine le météorite a-t-elle amie
ont-ils les dinosaures où étaient-ils
condamné d'avance à l'extinction entre
temps à drame en Alberta l'équipe du
Musée Royal a de bonnes raisons de
croire qu'un fossile de dinosaures assez
rare repose dans son site de fouille
l'équipe s'est lancée à la recherche de
dinosaures à cornes très particuliers la
rhinoceratops et au bout de quelques
jours à peine un de ces membres a trouvé
un fragment de mâchoire aujourd'hui la
chance leur sourit encore
on a trouvé une troisième mâchoire
inférieure c'est notre deuxième mâchoire
inférieure droite ce qui prouve qu'il y
a au moins deux dinosaures à cornes ici
à moins que notre dinosaure initial ait
eu de tête ce qui serait vraiment génial
mais raisonnablement je préfère croire
qu'il y a deux faux cils dans cette
couche de sol ce qui en fait un dépôt de
semaine
c'est une découverte importante et
François tergion entière des
informations sur le mode de vie de cette
mystérieuse créature ces animaux
vivaient sans doute en troupeau
c'est grâce à ce dépôt de seman qu'on
peut l'affirmer aujourd'hui
tandis que le climat fluctuait et que
les sources de nourriture se
transformaient la rhinoceratops a réussi
à s'adapter aux nouveaux paysages
la présence des fossiles suggère que
même après les changements climatiques
la région avait conservé assez de
végétation pour nourrir des troupes pour
entier d'arinoceratops au cours des 4
millions d'années suivantes le climat
est demeurer fluctuant se réchauffant
parfois pour se refroidir de nouveau
durant cette période le nombre des
espèces de dinosaures a baissé mais ils
n'ont jamais abandonné leur trône
malgré cela les rois de la terre ont été
incapables de s'adapter à un changement
climatique catastrophique
des scientifiques croient quand heurtant
la terre le météorite y a creusé un trou
de 200 km de circonférence et de 20 km
de profondeur tout ce qui était dans le
rayon de l'explosion a été pulvérisé
l'Impact a provoqué un tsunami et
projeté dans l'air un nuage de débris
la chaleur intense a dû tout incinérer
dans un rayon de plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres et la tout brûlé en
provoquant des feux de forêt
gigantesques
c'était l'équivalent d'un hiver
nucléaire privé de la lumière du soleil
toute vie s'éteint
les températures ont chuté la flore des
climats chauds
laissant les dinosaures herbivores sans
nourriture sans soleil les plantes sont
mortes sans plantes les herbivores sont
morts et sans herbivores les carnivores
sont morts
[Musique]
finalement les charognards sont morts
aussi parce qu'on ne peut pas manger de
la viande pourrie indéfiniment
[Musique]
une des hypothèses principales de la
période d'extinction c'est que
l'influence de la taille a basculé en
faveur des espèces survivantes
la chaîne alimentaire a été inversée les
grands dinosaures à l'appétit démesurés
étaient condamnés
[Musique]
mais pour les petits une belle époque
commençait
je ne sais pas ce que les tortues les
crocodiles et les mammifères ont fait
mais ils s'en sont bien tirés
ayant besoin de moi de nourriture ils
ont réussi à s'accrocher et finalement à
s'épanouir
[Musique]
l'expédition de fouilles du professeur
Larson tire à sa fin son équipe n'a plus
qu'une chose à faire
transporter des fossiles des derniers
dinosaures de la planète jusqu'au camp
en tirant il faut commettre nos 6 mains
sous la charge
ces vestes protectrices en plâtre
contiennent les vestiges de l'El
muosaure
et l'épine dorsale d'un petit ornithomyé
[Musique]
à présent ils doivent transporter cette
trésor à pied jusqu'au camp à 6 km de la
et comme les plus grosses vestes pèsent
plus de 100 kg la promenade ne sera pas
de tout repos
tout est prêt
si vous commencez à glisser asseyez-vous
il n'y a aucune route dans les environs
l'équipe de Hans Larson revient donc aux
anciennes méthodes il y a 100 ans on
sortait les fossiles les Badlands
manuellement ou sur des traîneaux
[Musique]
du côté opposé
à partir d'ici ça ira très bien
[Musique]
dès que les fossiles sont en sécurité au
camp le chef d'équipe prépare un repas
de célébration arrosé d'essence
d'extinction
ce soir on prépare une paella au riz
avec de la coriandre fraîche cueillie
dans un chant voisin
on va y ajouter un peu de poudre de
limite KT
c'est-à-dire la couche de cendres
d'iridium qui a anéanti 75% de la vie
sur cette planète il y a 66 millions
d'années
certains plats ou pourrait-on manger une
paella garnie d'une pincée de limite
caté à part ici
et voilà mes amis votre paella à saveur
d'extinction de masse
une bonne part de la vie terrestre et là
dedans ça risque d'être croquant
la saveur du bacon se marie bien à celle
du dinosaure rôti
l'affaire de l'extinction des dinosaures
et résolu ainsi l'équipe de Miguel
abandonne l'extinction en faveur de la
création
à nos objectifs et de développer une
plus grosse queue et on voudrait créer
des doigts mobiles avec des griffes en
Alberta l'équipe du Musée royal terroll
en est à sa dernière journée de fouille
mais ce n'est pas au bout de ses
surprises on voit clairement qu'il y a
un crâne
après son expédition dans les Badlands
l'équipe du professeur Larson a pu
ajouter de nouvelles données à la
théorie de l'extinction massive et posez
un regard neuf sur un mystère datant de
66 millions d'années la cause de la mort
des dinosaures mais son travail est loin
d'être terminé
entre temps à Alberta François terrien
et l'équipe du Musée royal arrive à la
fin d'une incroyable expédition de
fouilles ils ont découvert un défaut de
fossiles très rares et répondu à
certaines questions d'origine
préhistorique au début on ne trouvait
aucune trace de crâne et on se demandait
si ça valait la peine de continuer
l'excavation
à présent on voit clairement qu'il y a
un crâne et il n'est plus question
d'abandonner le site mais il faudra
revenir car on ne pourra jamais finir
les fouilles cet été entre temps leur
dépôts d'ossements sera couvert de
bâches qui le garderont à l'abri de la
pluie et de la neige on a un peu de
ruban du ruban orange
mais en haut ça donnera l'alerte ici
comme en Alberta les chasseurs de
dinosaures se posent une question
fondamentale les dinosaures étaient-ils
voués à l'extinction avant même que la
chute de météorites ne selle leur destin
durant des millénaires leur nombre avait
été réduit par des forces
environnementales mais les plus forts
avaient survécu et ils auraient pu
retrouver un jour leur puissance d'antan
mais 135 millions d'années de domination
terrestres ont été irrévocablement
anéantis lorsqu'on astéroïde est entré
en collision avec la planète bleue
[Musique]
les géants ont disparu mais les petites
créatures vivent encore aujourd'hui y
compris les descendants des dinosaures
survivants qui portent le doux nom
d'oiseau
[Musique]
lorsque la fumée lescendre se sont
dissipés la terre à cicatrisé ses
blessures et créer un nouveau foyer pour
les survivants
au fil du temps ils s'y sont adaptés en
formant un nouveau royaume animal et en
produisant leur propre géant et une
espèce de mammifère pipette on est venu
à régner sur un monde où le cerveau
domine les muscles
oui
les dinosaures ont disparu depuis très
longtemps mais à Montréal Hans Larsson
croit qu'il y aurait peut-être moyen de
les ramener sur terre
je vais faire une injection
un des projets qu'on dirige dans ce labo
s'appelle projet poulet aux Orres en
utilisant des gènes de poulet il cessait
de recréer certaines caractéristiques de
leurs ancêtres dinosauresiens notre labo
n'est pas le parc du racisme loin de là
les oiseaux sont des dinosaures on joue
donc avec de l'ADN dinosaure on veut
simplement trafiquer l'embryologie pour
dévoiler certaines anatomies
préhistoriques
et de développer une plus grosse queue
et on voudrait créer des doigts mobiles
avec des griffes
un jour avec l'aide dégénéticiens on
dénouera peut-être des millions d'années
d'évolution et les dinosaures revivront
ils seront très petits en créer des
grosses à noraient aucun sens c'est un
rêve lointain qui appartient peut-être à
la science-fiction de nos jours les
dinosaures revivent grâce à leur
vestiges fossilisés et ils sont partout
les premiers fossiles ont été découverts
dans l'Ouest il y a 140 ans mais on sait
maintenant qu'ils sont dispersés à
travers tous les Canada d'un océan à
l'autre le Canada repose sur des
ressources naturelles extraordinaires
vestiges d'un monde ayant vécu il y a
des millions d'années elle sommeille
sous la surface de la Terre en attendant
leur découverte
un jour vous découvrirez d'autres
merveilles préhistoriques et vous
entendrez d'autres récits fantastiques
car nous allons rester sur la piste des
dinosaures
[Musique]